Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行在Airbnb上体验会更好。现在，你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大及其众多的当地隐藏瑰宝。我曾在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，制作组给我安排了住处。第二年，我就想，嘿，不管制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能给我，让我自己去找个更像社区的地方住，你懂吗？是的。我确实这么做了，我租了一间Airbnb，一个小公寓，正对着公园，非常可爱。我喜欢那位房东，我在那里住了两个月。哇。是的，而且我离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得我在那里过上了一种小生活。我在想加拿大落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和阿尔伯塔落基山脉。我不知道，感觉如果你在那里给自己找个舒适的小木屋，你懂我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well, listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. When does fast delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without its grainy mustard. When the barbecue's lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner.
好吧，听着，也许你应该考虑在下一次冒险中选择Airbnb。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。Instacart的快速送货在什么时候最重要？当你的招牌芥末籽土豆沙拉没有了芥末籽就不再出名的时候。当烧烤架点着了，却没什么可烤的时候。当公婆决定，其实他们要留下来吃晚饭的时候。
Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus, enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders, service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. Hello and welcome to your second drink of Initiation with BJ Novak and Rainn Wilson. Yes, this episode featured our first double interview and I think our only double interview. I remember doing this on Zoom with those guys
Instacart这个夏天能满足你所有的杂货需求。所以下载应用程序，最快60分钟内送达。此外，前三单享受$0配送费，服务费、除外条款和条件适用。Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。你好，欢迎收听BJ·诺瓦克和雷恩·威尔森带来的第二杯《Initiation》。是的，这一集是我们第一次双人采访，我想也是我们唯一的一次双人采访。我记得当时是在Zoom上和他们做的，
because it was during COVID and we were podcasting from home. Yeah, I mean, it was really fun. Yeah, people loved it. We got a lot of nice letters after it ran like this one from Shelly B. Shelly said, just a comment. I love, love, love when you have guests on Office Ladies from the show. I am listening to Initiation with BJ Novak
因为那是新冠疫情期间，我们是在家里录制播客。是的，我是说，这真的很有趣。是的，大家都很喜欢。节目播出后我们收到了很多很好的来信，比如这封来自Shelly B的。Shelly说，只是个评论。我超爱、超爱、超爱你们邀请《办公室》剧组的演员来做客《Office Ladies》。我正在听BJ·诺瓦克和雷恩·威尔森那一集《Initiation》，
and Rainn Wilson, and it feels like coming home. I listen to your podcasts while I walk my dogs and I'm smiling and chuckling the whole time. Jenna and Angela, you do such a beautiful job with this podcast, and I admit to re-listening to them over and over, especially during this COVID time. I have my Office family with me on my breaks while working from home and it enriches my life.
感觉就像回家一样。我遛狗的时候听你们的播客，全程都在微笑和轻笑。珍娜和安吉拉，你们把这个播客做得太棒了，我承认我一遍又一遍地重听，特别是在这个新冠疫情期间。我在居家办公的休息时间里有我的“办公室家人”陪伴，这丰富了我的生活。
Thank you both. That is so sweet. So Shelly B was a big fan of this episode. Yeah. Well, as you all know, this is the episode where Dwight takes Ryan to Shroop Farms to put him through an initiation process for becoming a salesperson.
谢谢你们俩。太贴心了。所以Shelly B是这一集的忠实粉丝。是的。好吧，正如你们所知，这一集是德怀特带瑞安去施鲁特农场，让他经历成为销售员的入职流程。
The process has nothing to do with being a salesperson. I mean, in Dwight's mind it does. Yes. for becoming a salesperson. The process has nothing to do with being a salesperson. I mean, it's very loosely. In twice's mind it does. Yes, yes. I ended up rewatching this entire episode and I'm gonna have to log it as one of my favorites. We got this letter from Leah S. who said,
这个流程和成为销售员毫无关系。我是说，在德怀特看来是有关系的。是的。成为销售员。这个流程和成为销售员毫无关系。我是说，非常勉强。在德怀特看来是有关系的。是的，是的。我最终重看了这一整集，我得把它列为我最喜欢的剧集之一。我们收到了Leah S.的来信，她说，
Oh my God, you guys, I'm listening to your episode about initiation and I have some insider info for you about the TripAdvisor page for Shroot Farms. Oh yeah? Now there's no mention of TripAdvisor in this specific episode, but this was the episode that sort of triggered it for Leah. Leah said, I'm a graphic designer
天哪，你们，我正在听你们关于《Initiation》的那一集，我有一些关于施鲁特农场TripAdvisor页面的内幕消息要告诉你们。哦，是吗？这一集里并没有提到TripAdvisor，但这集是引发Leah关注的导火索。Leah说，我是一名平面设计师，
and I worked at TripAdvisor as an intern one summer during college. The page that was created to use as an example page within the Trip Advisor, like sort of internal system. Yes, exactly. It was the page that the creative team would use to make mock-ups of designs, and they would use it whenever a sample page was needed for whatever reason. It was for Shroot Farms.
大学期间曾在TripAdvisor做过一个暑假的实习生。那个被创建出来作为TripAdvisor内部系统示例页面的页面。是的，没错。那是创意团队用来制作设计样稿的页面，无论出于什么原因需要示例页面时，他们都会使用它。那就是施鲁特农场的页面。
That's so great. And the page was used, it was referenced a lot. Leah said, at least when I worked there, she said, I just thought you would appreciate this info. Love the pod. I do. I do too. Well, we also got this letter about the scene
太棒了。而且那个页面被使用，被引用了很多次。Leah说，至少在我工作的时候，她说，我只是觉得你们会喜欢这个信息。喜欢这个播客。我也喜欢。我也喜欢。好吧，我们还收到了关于那个场景的来信，
when Dwight is showing Ryan the barn. It's from Emily A. Emily said, just semantics, but in the initiation episode in the barn scene, Dwight called it a coffin. It is, in fact, a casket. A coffin is a wooden box wide at the shoulders and tapered at the head and feet. A casket is rectangular and what is widely used today. This has always bothered me because I'm crazy."
就是德怀特带瑞安看谷仓的时候。来自Emily A.。Emily说，只是语义上的问题，在《Initiation》那一集的谷仓场景中，德怀特称它为“coffin”（棺材）。实际上，那是一个“casket”（灵柩）。棺材（coffin）是一个在肩部较宽，在头脚两端变窄的木盒。灵柩（casket）是长方形的，也是今天广泛使用的。这一直困扰着我，因为我有点强迫症。
Emily, I appreciate you pointing this out because I believe Dwight K. Schrute would have known the difference. I believe he would too. I think this is a fantastic catch. And Emily, it's making me want to deep dive. When did it go from coffin to casket? What was the timeline of that? Oh, now I'm not gonna be able to sleep
Emily，我很感谢你指出这一点，因为我相信德怀特·K·施鲁特应该知道其中的区别。我相信他也知道。我觉得这是一个非常精彩的发现。而且Emily，这让我想要深入研究一下。它是从什么时候从coffin变成casket的？那个时间线是什么样的？哦，现在我没法睡觉了，
till I deep dive that. I know. I'm very curious. We also got a letter from Sophie A. who said, "'Not a question, but something you missed in the episode initiation. I was watching the episode a few days after the podcast came out, and I noticed something you guys did not talk about.
直到我深入研究完这个问题。我知道。我很好奇。我们还收到了Sophie A.的来信，她说：“不是问题，但你们在《Initiation》那一集中漏掉了一些东西。我在播客播出几天后重看了那一集，我注意到了一些你们没有谈到的事情。
At eight minutes and 12 seconds, when Jim is singing, Love Fool, to get back at Karen and annoy her, you can see Josh break character and throw the peace sign to the camera. It's just a tiny thing I noticed when rewatching the episode and I thought it was hilarious. I can't believe I missed it the first seven times.
在8分12秒时，当吉姆为了报复凯伦并惹恼她而唱《Love Fool》时，你可以看到乔什脱离了角色，对着镜头比了个和平手势。这只是我在重看这一集时注意到的一个小细节，我觉得太搞笑了。我不敢相信前七次看的时候我都错过了。
Did you see it when you rewatched? No. I didn't see it. I mean, until I read her letter. Oh, and then you saw it. Yes. Right. I didn't see it the first time either. No. All right. Next letter is from Kimberly T. Who says, first of all, I love the podcast.
你重看的时候看到了吗？没有。我没看到。我是说，直到我读了她的信。哦，然后你就看到了。是的。对。我第一次也没看到。没有。好吧。下一封信来自Kimberly T.。她说，首先，我爱这个播客。
I have a commute to work, but I don't mind if I'm listening to you ladies. I don't have a question, but I do have a funny. I like that. Yeah. I have a funny. I just got my insurance license and have started a new job with none other than State Farm.
我每天通勤上班，但听着你们的节目我就不觉得烦了。我没有问题，但我有一个趣事。我喜欢这个。是的。我有一个趣事。我刚拿到了保险执照，并在State Farm找到了一份新工作。
I was listening to the initiation during my first week there and y'all brought up the bit about the squeaky chair. I was given the squeaky chair, guys. I got the squeaky chair as part of my initiation at the office. I couldn't help but laugh and somewhat identify with that particular episode. Thank you ladies for doing this podcast.
我在那里的第一周听了《Initiation》，你们提到了吱吱作响的椅子那个梗。我被分配到了那把吱吱作响的椅子，伙计们。作为我在办公室入职的一部分，我得到了那把吱吱作响的椅子。我忍不住笑了，并且在某种程度上对那一集产生了共鸣。谢谢你们做这个播客。
It puts a smile on my face and gives me and my husband extra things to talk about during our busy week. See, the squeaky chair is a real thing. It's a real thing. All right, next up, Jackie C wrote in to say, you mentioned how someone was in the background at the Stanford branch standing at reception, like how Jim stands at reception talking to Pam.
它让我脸上露出笑容，也让我和丈夫在我们忙碌的一周里有了额外的话题。看，吱吱作响的椅子是真实存在的。它是真实存在的。好吧，接下来，Jackie C.写信来说，你们提到斯坦福分部背景里有人站在接待处，就像吉姆站在接待处和帕姆说话一样。
But ladies, no one mentioned how at 12 minutes and 43 seconds, there is a Pam lookalike at the copy machine at the Stanford branch. Frizzy hair, check. Striped pink button-down shirt, check. Striped pink button down shirt, check. This must be discussed. I mean, it's Stanford branch Pam. I saw it.
但是女士们，没人提到在12分43秒时，斯坦福分部的复印机旁有一个帕姆的模仿者。卷发，有。粉色条纹纽扣衬衫，有。粉色条纹纽扣衬衫，有。这必须讨论一下。我是说，那是斯坦福分部的帕姆。我看到了。
How did we miss that? I don't know. She is totally dressed like Pam, same hair, same outfit. Little Easter egg. Well, finally everyone, I mentioned in our breakdown that there were a lot of deleted scenes for this, and so many of them have been added back to the superfan version of the episode.
我们怎么会错过那个？我不知道。她完全打扮得像帕姆，一样的发型，一样的装束。小彩蛋。好吧，最后各位，我在我们的解析中提到过，这一集有很多删减片段，其中很多已经被加回到了这一集的超级粉丝版本中。
I mentioned that my favorite is the scene with Dwight and Ryan in Michael's office. It's just before they are going to leave for Ryan's sales call. It has this long, awkward, three-way hug at the end, and then it leads into a new Pam talking head. The whole thing is so hilarious, I just thought we should hear it.
我提到我最喜欢的是德怀特和瑞安在迈克尔办公室的那个场景。就在他们要出发去瑞安的销售电话之前。最后有一个漫长、尴尬的三人拥抱，然后引出了一个新的帕姆访谈片段。整个过程太搞笑了，我只是觉得我们应该听听。
Take a good look at this boy. I always do. Because you are never going to see him again. If you lay a finger on him. Today is Ryan's first sales call and I am bringing this boy home, a full grown man. Well, would you look at that. Ah!
好好看看这个男孩。我总是这样。因为你再也见不到他了。如果你动他一根手指头。今天是瑞安的第一次销售电话，我要把这个男孩带回家，一个完全长大的男人。好吧，看看那个。啊！
Ha ha ha ha. Damn it, Dwight, come on. Dwight is taking Ryan on a sales call today. So if we find Ryan's body in a heavily wooded area tomorrow, I owe Jim $30. It's an old bet, but deal's a deal. Ha ha ha. So, I don't know.
哈哈哈哈。该死，德怀特，得了吧。德怀特今天带瑞安去打销售电话。所以如果明天我们在树林茂密的地方发现瑞安的尸体，我就欠吉姆30美元。这是一个老赌约，但愿赌服输。哈哈。所以，我不知道。
Her and Jim had an interesting bet. Well, I just love the fact too that it's Michael hugging Ryan and then Dwight tries to get in on the hug and Michael's so ticked off. He's like, this is my hug with Ryan. I know. Well, that's all we have for Second Drink. Please enjoy our breakdown of initiation with special guests, BJ Novak and Rainn Wilson. And thanks for writing in everyone.
她和吉姆有一个有趣的赌约。好吧，我也很喜欢迈克尔拥抱瑞安，然后德怀特试图加入拥抱，迈克尔非常恼火这一点。他说，这是我和瑞安的拥抱。我知道。好吧，这就是我们第二杯的全部内容。请欣赏我们对《Initiation》的解析，特别嘉宾是BJ·诺瓦克和雷恩·威尔森。谢谢大家的来信。
I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并分享独家的幕后故事，
that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hi, everybody. Welcome to Office Ladies. Bonjour. Bonjour. I don't know. I don't know.
只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你。我们是《Office Ladies》。大家好。欢迎收听《Office Ladies》。Bonjour（你好）。Bonjour。我不知道。我不知道。
I am wearing like this, this t-shirt is kind kind of like it's like really soft and shimmery But it's like also feels like pajamas and I think it's just got me in a I don't know and a mood to say Bonjour Angela when I first saw you I thought you were just wearing a black t-shirt And I was really disappointed because I showed up in my Pam teapot shirt for our recording Why I like to always wear an office ladies or office themed or use an office mug when we record I don't know. It's a thing. It's like you want to get in the mindset. Here's the thing guys, every single week, Jenna shows up, we hop on the zoomie zoom because that's our life right now. And she has on an
我穿的这件T恤，它摸起来真的很柔软，还有点闪光，但它也感觉像睡衣，我想这让我处于一种，我不知道，一种想说Bonjour的心情。安吉拉，当我第一次见到你时，我以为你只是穿了一件黑色T恤，我很失望，因为我穿着我的帕姆茶壶T恤来录音。为什么我总是喜欢在录音时穿《Office Ladies》或办公室主题的衣服，或者用办公室主题的杯子？我不知道。这是一种习惯。就像你想进入那种心态一样。是这样的，伙计们，每周，珍娜都会出现，我们跳上Zoom，因为这就是我们现在的生活。她穿着一件
office themed something shirt hoodie and you did this also when we would used to go in the studio, you would always have your hoodie. And today I was like, I better dress to match my lady friend. Well, I thought you were wearing a black t-shirt and then you started dancing to our theme song when it played. And I saw that it says office ladies. I wore our office lady shirt. Made me so happy.
办公室主题的衬衫或连帽衫，以前我们在录音室时你也会这样做，你总是穿着你的连帽衫。今天我心想，我最好穿得和我的好闺蜜相配。好吧，我以为你穿的是黑色T恤，然后你开始随着我们的主题曲跳舞。我看到上面写着《Office Ladies》。我穿了我们的《Office Ladies》衬衫。让我太开心了。
And then it made you speak French. So. Wait, what are we here to talk about, Jenna? We are here to talk about Initiation, season three, episode five, written by BJ Novak and directed by Randall Einhorn. There are a lot of good quotes in this one. I won't rapid fire them right now,
然后它让你开始说法语了。所以。等等，我们今天要谈什么，珍娜？我们要谈的是《Initiation》，第三季第五集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导。这一集里有很多好的台词。我现在不会快速连珠炮式地列举它们，
but there are some good quotes. Angela, last week when we did grief counseling, we had a lot of bird injuries and fiascos in our life. Has any type of initiation incident happened to you this week? Have I been initiated in my own house? Yeah. I mean, talk about an interesting topic if the answer is yes. No, but don't give my kids any ideas. They would be all over this. They'd be like, here's the thing, kid club initiation. Go into Isabelle's room, put on this fuzzy hat. Jump backwards three times.
但确实有一些好的台词。安吉拉，上周我们做悲伤辅导时，我们的生活中发生了很多鸟类伤害和闹剧。这周你有没有发生过任何类型的入职事件？我在自己家里被入职了吗？是的。我是说，如果答案是肯定的，那真是个有趣的话题。没有，但别给我的孩子们任何主意。他们会对此非常热衷。他们会说，是这样的，儿童俱乐部入职。走进伊莎贝尔的房间，戴上这顶毛茸茸的帽子。向后跳三次。
Make a duck sound. You're in the club. Sounds fun. I'm into it. All right, let's talk about this episode. I've got a summary for you. I'm very excited. This is a big episode, all right?
发出鸭子的声音。你就加入俱乐部了。听起来很有趣。我喜欢。好吧，让我们谈谈这一集。我为你准备了一个总结。我很兴奋。这是一集大制作，好吗？
Here's the main storyline. Dwight is taking Ryan on his first sales call. But it's not as simple as that. Of course it's not. It involves Dwight. It involves a trip to Dwight's farm. Yeah. And other places.
这是主要故事情节。德怀特带瑞安去他的第一次销售电话。但这并不像听起来那么简单。当然不是。它涉及德怀特。它涉及去德怀特的农场。是的。还有其他地方。
And his creepy cousin. Oh, we're gonna meet Moe's. And then, of course, back at Dunder Mifflin, lady, it's pretzel day. That's a big day. Big day. Stan Lee is so excited. It's a long line, but they're going to get some pretzels.
还有他那令人毛骨悚然的表弟。哦，我们要见莫斯了。然后，当然，回到邓德·米夫林，女士，今天是椒盐卷饼日。那是个大日子。大日子。斯坦利太兴奋了。队伍很长，但他们会得到一些椒盐卷饼。
However, at this same time, Jan has told Pam she has to keep a log of Michael's day and make sure he's productive. Meanwhile, over in Stanford, they've got a squeaky chair, they've got some more flirty flirt. Oh boy, let's get into it. Fast fact number one, as I said, we are going to visit Shroot Farm.
然而，与此同时，简告诉帕姆她必须记录迈克尔的一天，并确保他有成效。与此同时，在斯坦福，他们有一把吱吱作响的椅子，还有更多的调情。哦，天哪，让我们开始吧。第一个快速事实，正如我所说，我们要去参观施鲁特农场。
This is huge. We got a ton of questions about this. Are you ready for some names? I'm ready for some names. Who wrote in? Lauren Bales, Mike Motherwell, Jessica Cohen, Bailey Lawrence, and Brianna Bullard all said, where is the farm? Where is the farm where Ryan and Dwight go? Well I know that it was a few places. Did you hit up some Kintapedia? I did. So the main Trute Farm was shot at the Disney Ranch, which is also called the Golden Oak Ranch. It is a place where you shoot things. It's like an outdoor exterior shooting studio, basically. It's massive though. It's massive. It's acres and acres, right?
这太大了。我们收到了大量关于这个的问题。你准备好听一些名字了吗？我准备好了。谁写信来了？劳伦·贝尔斯、迈克·马瑟韦尔、杰西卡·科恩、贝利·劳伦斯和布里安娜·布拉德都说，农场在哪里？瑞安和德怀特去的那个农场在哪里？我知道它是在几个地方拍的。你查过Kintapedia了吗？我查了。所以主要的施鲁特农场是在迪士尼牧场拍摄的，也就是金橡树牧场。这是一个拍摄东西的地方。它基本上是一个户外外景拍摄工作室。不过它很大。它很大。它是几英亩几英亩的，对吧？
It's like, oh yeah, it's massive. And so so many movies that need this sort of rustic look have been filmed there. Like the history of Disney Ranch is really cool. Oh yeah. It's located in New Hall, California, which is about 17 miles from the Dunder Mifflin studios. I'm giving you that detail because several people asked how far away it was from our main studios, and I want them to feel satisfied.
就像，哦是的，它很大。所以很多需要这种乡村外观的电影都在那里拍摄过。迪士尼牧场的历史真的很酷。哦是的。它位于加利福尼亚州纽霍尔，距离邓德·米夫林工作室大约17英里。我给你这个细节是因为几个人问它离我们的主工作室有多远，我想让他们感到满意。
So there are several barns and farmhouses on this property. They chose one of them to be the Shroot Farmhouse, and then they created a graveyard next to it. But you might be thinking, wait a second, I don't remember a graveyard. That's because it's a deleted scene. It's a deleted scene. It's a really good deleted scene, you guys. If you have the DVDs, go watch it. So here's what happens. They're in the cemetery because Dwight wants to show Ryan how many shrewts have actually been buried on shrewt farms. And he has like his grandfather's tombstone
所以这个物业上有几个谷仓和农舍。他们选择了其中一个作为施鲁特农舍，然后在旁边建了一个墓地。但你可能在想，等一下，我不记得有墓地。那是因为那是一个删减片段。那是一个删减片段。这是一个非常好的删减片段，伙计们。如果你有DVD，去看看吧。事情是这样的。他们在墓地里，因为德怀特想向瑞安展示到底有多少施鲁特人被埋在施鲁特农场。他有他祖父的墓碑，
and he's like, my grandfather was a good man but did very bad things. So what is up with his grandfather? His grandfather was, I don't know, maybe not a great guy. Then Dwight finds like an empty, it looks like a beer can and he gets furious and he starts looking around
他说，我祖父是个好人，但做了非常坏的事情。那么他祖父是怎么回事？他祖父，我不知道，也许不是个好人。然后德怀特发现了一个空的，看起来像啤酒罐的东西，他变得非常愤怒，开始四处查看，
and he sees this couple, the guy like basically has no clothes on, he's like covering himself with his pants and a girl who barely has clothes and they start running through the field and Dwight's yelling at them. And this was awesome because it's a total callback to Office Olympics where Dwight mentions
他看到了这对情侣，那个男的基本上没穿衣服，他用裤子遮住自己，还有一个几乎没穿衣服的女孩，他们开始跑过田野，德怀特对着他们大喊大叫。这太棒了，因为这是对《办公室奥运会》的完全呼应，德怀特提到
that teenagers sometimes use the beat farm for sex. Oh, I'm so bummed this is not in the episode. It's a great scene. It's a really funny scene. Oh my gosh. I love a callback. And this is calling back creepy grandfather and the teenagers on the farm. And you know what?
青少年有时会利用甜菜农场进行性行为。哦，我很遗憾这一幕没有出现在剧集中。这是一个很棒的场景。这是一个非常有趣的场景。天哪。我喜欢呼应。这呼应了令人毛骨悚然的祖父和农场上的青少年。你知道吗？
When I watched it, all I could think about, since I filmed many scenes on Trute Farms, was the field they ran through. A, it was probably super hot. And B, it was snaky. since I filmed many scenes on Trout Farms, was the field they ran through. A, it was probably super hot, and B, it was snaky. We'll get to that later. But all I could think of was these people
当我观看它时，我能想到的，因为我在施鲁特农场拍摄过很多场景，就是他们跑过的田野。A，它可能超级热。B，它有很多蛇。我们稍后会谈到这一点。但我能想到的就是这些人
with not a lot of clothes on having to run through that sneaky field. I was like, oh. Yes, let's talk about those snakes, Angela, because Kent told me that the one requirement for shooting on the ranch is that every production has to hire a snake wrangler. Yeah. because the property has a history of rattlesnakes on the property. Yeah.
没穿多少衣服，不得不跑过那片有很多蛇的田野。我当时想，哦。是的，让我们谈谈那些蛇，安吉拉，因为肯特告诉我，在牧场拍摄的一个要求是每个制作组都必须雇佣一名捕蛇人。是的。因为该物业有响尾蛇的历史。是的。
Yeah. Oh, yeah. And Kent said the snake guy found a rattlesnake near that graveyard set. A five-foot rattlesnake, by the way. Oh, I don't doubt it. I don't doubt it. My memory- That's as big as you, Angela. It's my height.
是的。哦，是的。肯特说捕蛇人在那个墓地布景附近发现了一条响尾蛇。顺便说一句，一条五英尺长的响尾蛇。哦，我不怀疑。我不怀疑。我的记忆——那和你一样大，安吉拉。那是我的身高。
I have two more facts about Disney Ranch. Let's hear it. So the other location that we shot on Disney Ranch was that barn. Mm-hmm. That old barn, we also used that. And we used another house at the Disney Ranch for that scene at the bar at the end
关于迪士尼牧场我还有两个事实。让我们听听。所以我们在迪士尼牧场拍摄的另一个地点是那个谷仓。嗯。那个旧谷仓，我们也用了那个。我们在迪士尼牧场还用了另一所房子，用于最后在酒吧的那个场景，
when Dwight and Ryan are at the bar. That house that they used for the bar was originally built for Pee Wee Herman's show back in the 1980s and they redressed it and turned it into a bar. Isn't that amazing? That's crazy. I know. So there's a little fun fact. Yeah. And finally a lot of people wanted to know if we did keep going back to the same location to shoot year after year. And yes, we went back to the Disney ranch multiple times, including in season four, the money episode. That is when Pam catches Moe's in the outhouse. Yeah. And then we were there. Dwight and Angela have a scene in that barn years later. But then ultimately we'll get to this.
当德怀特和瑞安在酒吧时。他们用于酒吧的那所房子最初是为80年代皮威·赫尔曼的节目建造的，他们重新装饰了它，把它变成了酒吧。这不神奇吗？这太疯狂了。我知道。所以这是一个有趣的小事实。是的。最后，很多人想知道我们是否真的年复一年地回到同一个地点拍摄。是的，我们多次回到迪士尼牧场，包括第四季的《金钱》那一集。那是帕姆在厕所里抓住莫斯的时候。是的。然后我们在那里。德怀特和安吉拉多年后在那个谷仓里有一个场景。但最终我们会谈到这一点。
The final Shroop Farm scene of the whole series is in a whole new location that was so beautiful. But we'll get there. Yeah, that was gorgeous. It looked like we were in Scotland. It was so beautiful. Yes. But we don't go there till the end. Till the end end.
整个系列中最后一个施鲁特农场场景是在一个全新的地点，非常漂亮。但我们会谈到的。是的，那太华丽了。看起来我们好像在苏格兰。太美了。是的。但我们直到最后才去那里。直到最后。
Okay, guys, we'll get there in three years. We'll get there. Till the end end. Okay, guys, we'll get there in three years. We'll get there. Fast fact number two, the beet fields were not shot at Disney Ranch. That was a completely different location. Those scenes were shot at the Underwood Family Farm in Moorpark, California. It is a real working 200 acre farm.
好吧，伙计们，我们三年后会谈到的。我们会谈到的。第二个快速事实，甜菜田不是在迪士尼牧场拍摄的。那是一个完全不同的地点。那些场景是在加利福尼亚州穆尔帕克的安德伍德家庭农场拍摄的。这是一个真正的200英亩的工作农场。
They grow corn, carrots, kale, strawberries, tomatoes, and of course beets. So we filmed those in an actual beet field. Isn't that crazy? That is crazy. I have been to that farm with Isabel, my daughter, for a school field trip and I went on a hay ride through like all around. Oh yeah. It's like a, it's a huge farm and it's just, it's not that far away. All right, moving us along to fast fact number three. This was the first episode directed by Randall Einhorn. And you guys, so Randall was our cinematographer
他们种植玉米、胡萝卜、羽衣甘蓝、草莓、西红柿，当然还有甜菜。所以我们是在一个真正的甜菜田里拍摄的。这不疯狂吗？这太疯狂了。我和我的女儿伊莎贝尔去过那个农场参加学校的实地考察，我坐着干草车绕了一圈。哦是的。它是一个巨大的农场，而且离得不远。好吧，让我们继续第三个快速事实。这是兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导的第一集。伙计们，兰德尔是我们的摄影师，
and our A camera operator. You've heard us talk about him a lot. We loved him, we loved him. He was just so fun. And this was a, this was like a big deal. Like the cast was so excited to see Randall direct an episode. I got on the phone with Randall. Angela. You did. I love him.
也是我们的A机位操作员。你们听我们谈论过他很多次。我们爱他，我们爱他。他真的太有趣了。这是一个大事件。演员们非常兴奋看到兰德尔执导一集。我给兰德尔打了电话。安吉拉。你打了。我爱他。
Yes. And we're gonna have him on the show. He told me that this was his first directing job ever. He told me that this was his first directing job ever. He told me that before our show, he had only ever worked on documentary style projects. And remember we said he was a camera operator on Survivor. Yeah. But he had done all this other documentary work as well.
是的。我们要请他上节目。他告诉我这是他有史以来第一份导演工作。他告诉我这是他有史以来第一份导演工作。他告诉我，在我们的节目之前，他只做过纪录片风格的项目。还记得我们说过他是《幸存者》的摄像师吗？是的。但他还做过所有这些其他的纪录片工作。
Yeah. He used to film like, I think like river boat, crazy river rafting stuff in Australia. Like he is like a tough guy. And I think the documentary style, like we said, was perfect for our show. And now he gets to direct. Yeah, he said he couldn't believe he got the job
是的。他过去常拍摄，我想是像河船，澳大利亚疯狂的漂流之类的东西。他就像一个硬汉。我认为纪录片风格，正如我们所说，非常适合我们的节目。现在他可以执导了。是的，他说他不敢相信他得到了这份工作，
as our cinematographer because he had never worked in scripted anything before. And now Greg was telling him to direct, and he was like, what? But he said that Greg was really sweet. Greg said, Randall, all the time, you are finding jokes with your camera. And this is a natural extension of that. And so Randall was like, all right, I'll do it.
作为我们的摄影师，因为他以前从未从事过任何剧本创作。现在格雷格让他执导，他当时想，什么？但他确实说格雷格真的很贴心。格雷格一直对兰德尔说，你总是用你的摄像机发现笑话。这是对此的自然延伸。所以兰德尔想，好吧，我做。
And he said, he was so touched because he felt like everyone in the cast and crew was rooting for him to succeed. Randall was like, all right, I'll do it. And he said he was so touched because he felt like everyone in the cast and crew was rooting for him to succeed. He said he'll just never forget what that support felt like and what it meant to him. He said, especially BJ, who was the writer of the episode, he said the hardest part of directing this episode, because I said to him, I'm like, Randall,
他说他非常感动，因为他觉得演员和剧组里的每个人都在为他的成功加油。他说他永远不会忘记那种支持的感觉以及它对他意味着什么。他说，特别是BJ，他是这一集的编剧，他说执导这一集最难的部分，因为我对他说，我说，兰德尔，
this was a huge episode. You have to introduce Pretzel Day, Shroot Farms, and Moe's, and then it all ends with this epic phone call between Jim and Pam. What was the hardest part of all that? And he said the hardest part was not holding the camera himself. Well, yeah.
这是一集大制作。你必须介绍椒盐卷饼日、施鲁特农场和莫斯，然后这一切都以吉姆和帕姆之间那场史诗般的电话结束。所有这些中最难的部分是什么？他说最难的部分是不能自己拿着摄像机。好吧，是的。
Yeah, that's so true. Because that was his background for years, you know, but I think it made him such a great director because he had that vision. He knew where he wanted the camera. He knew what he wanted the camera to see. I loved that. Well, he said he did take the camera a few times during this episode and he even pointed them out to me. So I'll tell you those moments as we go along. Oh, fun. He also told me that even today when he's directing,
是的，那太真实了。因为那是他多年的背景，你知道，但我认为这使他成为了一位伟大的导演，因为他有那种愿景。他知道他想要摄像机在哪里。他知道他想要摄像机看到什么。我喜欢这一点。好吧，他说他在这一集中确实拿了几次摄像机，他甚至向我指出了那些时刻。所以当我们继续时，我会告诉你们那些时刻。哦，有趣。他还告诉我，即使在今天，当他执导时，
because that's what he does now. He's now a director exclusively. And he said it was only last year that he finally directed a project and didn't take the camera once. Wow. But he said that's how he feels it that way still, because those were his beginnings. Yeah.
因为这就是他现在所做的。他现在专门做导演。他说直到去年他才终于执导了一个项目，一次都没有拿过摄像机。哇。但他说他仍然有那种感觉，因为那是他的起点。是的。
Well, before he directed this episode, he directed the webisodes. Oh, yes. And so, you know, obviously, that's not like a full episode, but I remember how giddy he was. But he was holding the camera and directing, because that was just us on the weekend. It was just like three of us there.
好吧，在他执导这一集之前，他执导了网络剧集。哦，是的。所以，你知道，显然，那不像完整的一集，但我记得他有多么兴奋。但他拿着摄像机并执导，因为那只是我们在周末拍摄。当时只有我们三个人在那里。
And you guys won an Emmy for those webisodes. We did, we won an Emmy. I have an Emmy for the accountants. I know. It just tickles me. So cool. All right, listen, why don't we take a break and then we're gonna come back and start breaking down this episode. Okay.
你们为那些网络剧集赢得了艾美奖。我们赢了，我们赢了艾美奖。我有一个《会计师》的艾美奖。我知道。这让我很开心。太酷了。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下，然后回来开始解析这一集。好的。
and start breaking down this episode. Okay. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. Lady, did you see that hilarious Saturday night live sketch they did about men's health and mental health where like in order to trick men into taking care of themselves, they made a medical clinic that is like a podcast, like a Dude Bro podcast. Oh my gosh, it's so funny. But it's also because it's kind of true. Men
开始解析这一集。好的。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。女士，你看到他们做的那个关于男性健康和心理健康的搞笑《周六夜现场》小品了吗？为了诱骗男性照顾自己，他们建立了一个医疗诊所，就像一个播客，一个Dude Bro播客。哦，天哪，太搞笑了。但这也很真实，因为某种程度上是真的。男性
are often reluctant to take the time to dig into their mental health. I've got a stat for you. Six million men in the U.S. suffer from depression every year and it's often undiagnosed. So listen, if you're a man and you're feeling the weight of the world, we would like to encourage you to talk to someone. A friend, a loved one, a therapist. Maybe you want to give BetterHelp a try. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to
通常不愿意花时间去深入了解他们的心理健康。我有一个统计数据。美国每年有六百万男性患有抑郁症，而且通常未被诊断。所以听着，如果你是一名男性，并且感到世界的重压，我们想鼓励你和某人谈谈。朋友、爱人、治疗师。也许你想试试BetterHelp。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供
mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at betterhelp.com slash office ladies. That's betterhelp.com slash office ladies. It's a real privilege to be out to travel and to see different places. Taking yourself out comfortable positions and challenging yourself. No one builds a legacy by standing still. Start your journey at Remover.com.
具有多种专业知识的心理健康专业人员。和BetterHelp谈谈吧。我们的听众在betterhelp.com/officeladies上首次订购可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp.com/officeladies。能够旅行和看到不同的地方是一种真正的特权。让自己走出舒适区并挑战自己。没有人通过原地踏步来建立遗产。在Remover.com开始你的旅程。
Okay, so now we're in the episode, guys, and Dwight is challenging Ryan to a brain teaser. And, you know, Ryan just crushes it. He knows all of them. Dwight is challenging Ryan to a brain teaser and you know Ryan just crushes it he knows all of them Dwight gets really frustrated I found this little piece of trivia on Dunderpedia and Jenna I loved it Dunderpedia is amazing if you guys haven't checked it out. Dunderpedia is amazing everybody. Alright so on Dunderpedia it says one of the riddles that Dwight poses to Ryan in the cold open is about a boy involved in a car accident who is the son of the doctor poses to Ryan in the cold open is about a boy involved in a car accident
好的，现在我们进入这一集了，伙计们，德怀特正在用脑筋急转弯挑战瑞安。而且，你知道，瑞安完全碾压了它。他知道所有这些。德怀特正在用脑筋急转弯挑战瑞安，你知道瑞安完全碾压了它，他知道所有这些。德怀特变得非常沮丧。我在Dunderpedia上发现了这个小花絮，珍娜，我喜欢它。Dunderpedia太棒了，如果你们还没看过的话。Dunderpedia太棒了，大家。好吧，所以在Dunderpedia上说，德怀特在冷开场中向瑞安提出的谜题之一是关于一个男孩卷入了一场车祸，他是急诊室里医生的儿子，
who is the son of the doctor on the call in the emergency room and therefore cannot operate even though his father was in the car and was also injured because the doctor is his mother, right? Yes. Get this. At the very end of the finale of the original BBC series, Tim, which, you know, the character Jim is based on, along with Gareth, and that's the character Dwight was based on, is being asked this riddle by David Brent. Wow!
因此无法手术，尽管他的父亲在车里也受伤了，因为医生是他的母亲，对吧？是的。听着。在原版BBC系列剧的大结局最后，蒂姆，你知道，吉姆这个角色就是基于他，还有加雷斯，也就是德怀特这个角色所基于的人，被大卫·布伦特问了这个谜题。哇！
Isn't that so cool? I feel like this is a little nod, right? Yeah. I loved that. I love that too. Well, then, when this episode really begins, Jan is in Michael's office. She's trying to have a professional conversation
这不酷吗？我觉得这是一个小小的致敬，对吧？是的。我喜欢那个。我也喜欢。好吧，然后，当这一集真正开始时，简在迈克尔的办公室里。她试图进行专业的对话
with Michael, but he keeps making it personal. Yeah. Jenna, here's, did you notice her hair in this scene? How can you not? What is going on with her hair? I don't know. It's like they tried something new. They tried rollers or something.
与迈克尔，但他总是把它变成个人的。是的。珍娜，你注意到她在这个场景里的头发了吗？怎么可能不注意？她的头发怎么了？我不知道。就像他们尝试了什么新东西。他们尝试了卷发器之类的东西。
I was like. It looks like hot rollers. It looks like hot rollers. I was just like, wait, they were just doing blowouts. And now Jan, Jan is zhuzhing it up when she comes in to see Michael now. That's an interesting take on it. Like he's talking about the sex he's having with Carol
我当时想。看起来像热卷发器。看起来像热卷发器。我当时只是想，等等，他们刚才还在做吹风造型。现在简，简进来见迈克尔时把头发弄得蓬松。这是一个有趣的看法。就像他在谈论他和卡罗尔发生的性关系，
and she's like, I did not hot roller my hair for this. For this BS. Yeah. I totally noticed her hair. Well, then Jan goes up to Pam's desk and says that she needs to keep an hourly log of Michael's activity so that corporate can analyze his productivity. You guys, there's a moment in this scene
而她就像，我没有为了这个而用热卷发器弄头发。为了这些废话。是的。我完全注意到了她的头发。好吧，然后简走到帕姆的桌子前，说她需要记录迈克尔每小时的活动，以便公司分析他的生产力。伙计们，在这个场景里有一个时刻
that made me laugh so hard when I was rewatching it. And also, I remember breaking every time Melora did it. What? She walks up to the desk. I'll tell you. She walks up to the desk and she's like, hi, Pam, and Pam goes, hi. And then she goes, I'm great.
当我重看时让我笑得太厉害了。而且，我记得每次梅洛拉做那个动作时我都会笑场。什么？她走到桌子前。我会告诉你的。她走到桌子前，她说，嗨，帕姆，帕姆说，嗨。然后她说，我很好。
And then keeps talking, but Pam didn't say, how are you? Yeah. She's so pissed that Michael has just told her about Carol and she just walks up with that energy. I love it so much. So, you know, I got the shooting drafts for this whole season and it's in there. I'm great is in there.
然后继续说话，但帕姆没有说，你好吗？是的。她对迈克尔刚才告诉她关于卡罗尔的事感到非常生气，她带着那种能量走过来。我太喜欢了。所以，你知道，我拿到了这一整季的拍摄草稿，它就在里面。“我很好”就在里面。
I had to look it up to see if Malora improvised that or if it was written, but that was a written joke and I love it. So good. We had some mail about this scene. Lauren Hallman wrote in to say, at one minute 47 seconds, there's a weird circular object in the bottom right next to an ancient stapler that I can't identify. And Elizabeth Molina said, what's the deal with the scale behind Jenna? It looks like a food scale, which would make more sense in the kitchen or break room. I think they're talking about the same object. I froze on it. It is a scale. I think it's a scale that Pam is using to weigh small packages for mailing. Yeah, I would think it was probably
我不得不查一下看看梅洛拉是即兴发挥的还是写好的，但那是一个写好的笑话，我喜欢它。太棒了。我们收到了一些关于这个场景的邮件。劳伦·霍尔曼写信说，在1分47秒，一个古老的订书机旁边有一个奇怪的圆形物体，我无法识别。伊丽莎白·莫利纳说，珍娜身后的秤是怎么回事？看起来像食物秤，在厨房或休息室里更有意义。我想他们说的是同一个物体。我定格看了。那是一个秤。我想那是帕姆用来称量小包裹邮寄的秤。是的，我会认为它可能是
to make sure she has the right postage. That's what it looked like to me. We don't have a mail room in our office. We have a mail cart. So I guess Pam has to keep that scale behind her, but it's not always there. Listen, we don't know what Pam does back there. With her revolving plants and her scale.
为了确保她有正确的邮资。这就是它给我的感觉。我们的办公室里没有收发室。我们有一个邮件车。所以我猜帕姆必须把那个秤放在她身后，但它并不总是在那里。听着，我们不知道帕姆在后面做什么。带着她旋转的植物和她的秤。
She can't keep a plant alive. She has a giant shredder. Yeah. And now she has a scale. We don't know. We don't know. Well, guys, now we are going to find out that Dwight is taking Ryan on this sales call, his first sales call. Oh, he's so excited. There are some great deleted scenes on the DVD that are all about this storyline. But Dwight is so excited.
她连一株植物都养不活。她有一个巨大的碎纸机。是的。现在她有一个秤。我们不知道。我们不知道。好吧，伙计们，现在我们要发现德怀特要带瑞安去打这个销售电话，他的第一次销售电话。哦，他太兴奋了。DVD上有一些很棒的删减片段，都是关于这个故事情节的。但德怀特太兴奋了。
He's hoping that Ryan will become part of the Dwight's army of champions, right? Yeah. Not be a slacker like Jim. This is like, and maybe, maybe become one of his best friends. Maybe. So in the DVDs, there's a deleted scene that I absolutely loved. I laughed so hard and it's just such a simple moment, you guys. But Michael goes to hug Ryan to wish him well as he goes out for his first sale.
他希望瑞安能成为德怀特冠军军队的一部分，对吧？是的。不像吉姆那样懒散。这就像，也许，也许成为他最好的朋友之一。也许。所以在DVD里，有一个我绝对喜欢的删减片段。我笑得太厉害了，这只是一个简单的时刻，伙计们。但迈克尔去拥抱瑞安，祝他在第一次销售中好运。
You know, like, I'm going to give you a man hug. It's awkward. It's so awkward. But then it gets even weirder because then Dwight joins in and he wants to hug him too. And then Michael's like shoving Dwight like, Dwight, get away. Like, meanwhile, like, BJ is like stuck between them. It is it's it just made me laugh so hard. I love this whole storyline. We know you love it too.
你知道，就像，我要给你一个男人拥抱。这很尴尬。太尴尬了。但后来变得更奇怪了，因为德怀特加入了，他也想拥抱他。然后迈克尔就像推开德怀特，德怀特，走开。就像，与此同时，BJ就像被夹在他们中间。这太搞笑了，我笑得太厉害了。我喜欢整个故事情节。我们知道你也喜欢它。
We have a surprise. We have a surprise. Tell them Jenna. Rain and BJ are gonna come on the show today to talk all about it. So we're gonna break down the rest of the episode and then when they hop on, they will discuss all things,
我们有一个惊喜。我们有一个惊喜。告诉他们，珍娜。雷恩和BJ今天会来节目谈论这一切。所以我们要解析这一集的其余部分，然后当他们加入时，他们将讨论所有事情，
shrewt farms and the initiation. Yes, we're going to skip their scenes for now. But don't worry, we will get to it. For now, let's discuss what's going on at Stanford. Oh yeah, at 3 minutes 21 seconds, Karen notices that Jim took her chair and has replaced it with the squeaky chair. I want you to know something, squeaky chair was not in the original script. Huh.
施鲁特农场和入职。是的，我们现在要跳过他们的场景。但别担心，我们会谈到的。现在，让我们讨论一下斯坦福发生了什么。哦是的，在3分21秒，凯伦注意到吉姆拿走了她的椅子，并用吱吱作响的椅子代替了它。我想让你们知道一件事，吱吱作响的椅子不在最初的剧本里。嗯。
The original storyline for Stanford was completely different. This was a late edition. And I traded some texts with BJ and he said he doesn't quite remember where the squeaky chair storyline came from. Let me give you a little pitch where it might have come from and it might not have, but
斯坦福最初的故事情节完全不同。这是一个后期添加的内容。我和BJ交换了一些短信，他说他不记得吱吱作响的椅子故事情节是从哪里来的。让我给你们一个小推测，它可能来自哪里，也可能没有，但
I want you guys to know something happening behind the scenes was over in the accounting department and I texted Oscar. I was like, Oscar, do you remember this? And he just wrote back, ha ha ha ha ha. Okay. There was a crap chair over in accounting. It was an absolute piece of crap chair that it wouldn't go up and down. It just was like set on one setting. So it was always way too low for my desk.
我想让你们知道幕后发生的事情是在会计部门，我给奥斯卡发了短信。我说，奥斯卡，你记得这个吗？他只是回信说，哈哈哈哈。好吧。会计部门有一把烂椅子。那绝对是一把烂椅子，它不能上下调节。它就像固定在一个设置上。所以它对我的桌子来说总是太低了。
And then it leaned way too far back. So you always felt like, like, I mean, you guys, I know I'm Southern, but I always felt like I was going to get bucked out of it. I'd be like, that's a chair is going to buck me out. So sometimes I would go and it would be at my desk and I'd be like, son of a gun, Oscar switched it again. It just traded back and forth between me and Oscar. I would move his chair and I'd put the crap chair at his desk. And then out of nowhere after lunch, it would be back at my desk.
然后它向后倾斜得太远了。所以你总是觉得，就像，我是说，伙计们，我知道我是南方人，但我总是觉得我要被它甩出去了。我会想，那把椅子要甩我出去。所以有时我会去，它会在我的桌子上，我会想，该死，奥斯卡又换了它。它就在我和奥斯卡之间来回换。我会移动他的椅子，把烂椅子放在他的桌子上。然后午饭后不知从哪冒出来，它又回到了我的桌子上。
And I'd be like, Oscar, you gave me this piece of crap chair again. We must have done this, I think for weeks. And then one day I moved it over to Creed's desk. Oh no, Angela. I did. And I said to Oscar, I was like, I put that crap chair at Creed's desk.
我会想，奥斯卡，你又给了我这把烂椅子。我们一定这样做，我想有几周了。然后有一天我把它移到了克里德的桌子上。哦不，安吉拉。我做了。我对奥斯卡说，我把那把烂椅子放在克里德的桌子上了。
And we like laughed. And anyway, it just cracks me up that this was actually something happening. I don't know if the writers ever even knew about it. I don't know if we vented about it, but this was an actual thing happening over in accounting. Oh my gosh, you had your own chair wore. We did, but I don't know how Brian stayed out of it.
我们笑了。总之，这事儿居然真的发生了，让我觉得特别好笑。我不知道编剧们是否知道这件事。我不知道我们有没有为此发过牢骚，但这确实是会计部发生的一件真事。天哪，你们还有自己的椅子保卫战。我们确实有，但我不知道布莱恩是怎么置身事外的。
Maybe because he was too far in the corner. Yeah. It just traded between me and Oscar. Well, did you notice in this scene in Stanford when Jim wheels his chair over to the copier? Did you look in the background? I noticed a little something back there. I saw a few people write in.
也许是因为他坐在角落里太远了。是啊。这把椅子就在我和奥斯卡之间换来换去。对了，你在斯坦福这一幕里，看到吉姆把椅子滑到复印机旁了吗？你注意看背景了吗？我注意到了后面的一点小东西。我看到有几个人写信提到了。
You have to tell them because I think this is so beautiful. All right. I also talked to Randall about this and he said this was totally on purpose. He planted a guy standing at reception in the same way that Jim would always stand at reception and talk to Pam. He even has his sleeves rolled up the way Jim used to roll up his sleeves. Sleeve gate. Susan, are you listening to this, Susan? Yeah, I know. Susan, who broke down the sleeves. Yeah. And Randall said that was on purpose
你一定要告诉他们，因为我觉得这太美好了。好吧。我也和兰德尔谈过这件事，他说这完全是故意的。他安排了一个人站在前台，就像吉姆以前总是站在前台和帕姆聊天那样。他甚至把袖子卷起来的方式都和吉姆以前卷袖子的方式一模一样。袖子门。苏珊，你在听吗，苏珊？是啊，我知道。苏珊，就是那个分析袖子的人。是啊。兰德尔说那是故意的。
to keep that Pam-Jim thing sort of in our orbit. Oh my gosh, that's such a beautiful detail. So Stanford has their own version of Jim and Pam that hang out at reception and flirt. Yeah. Amazing, right? That's amazing. That's amazing. All right, So let's go back to the Scranton branch. Pam is keeping notes on Michael's day. He's on a phone call and he's doing a Bill Cosby impression. So Pam holds up her log and she has written Cosby impression. So first of all, that is not my handwriting on the log, people asked. And also we got a fan question from Jonathan Barak.
为了让帕姆和吉姆的那种感觉留在我们的轨道里。天哪，这细节太美好了。所以斯坦福也有他们自己的吉姆和帕姆，在前台闲逛调情。是啊。太棒了，对吧？太神奇了。太神奇了。好了，让我们回到斯克兰顿分部。帕姆正在记录迈克尔的一天。他正在打电话，还在模仿比尔·考斯比。所以帕姆举起她的记录本，上面写着“模仿考斯比”。首先，那上面的字迹不是我的，有人问过。而且我们还收到了乔纳森·巴拉克的一个粉丝提问。
When Jan gives Pam a timesheet to write down everything Michael does throughout the day, why doesn't Pam cover for him? Like why not write down sales call instead of Cosby impression? Hmm. What are our thoughts on that? I mean, Pam sometimes is a little bit of a stickler. She's a role follower, you know? Yeah. I mean, I think if she covers for Michael and then Jan finds out otherwise,
当简给帕姆一张工时表，让她记录迈克尔全天所做的一切时，为什么帕姆不帮他打掩护呢？比如为什么不写“销售电话”而不是“模仿考斯比”？嗯。我们对此有什么看法？我是说，帕姆有时候有点死板。她是个循规蹈矩的人，你知道吗？是啊。我是说，我觉得如果她帮迈克尔打掩护，然后简发现了真相，
Pam's gonna get in trouble. Yeah. I mean, I feel like she does cover for him later. So maybe she starts out being like, all right, I'll do what Jan told me, but then she feels bad or something, because Michael is such a train wreck for the whole day. Yeah. And he ends up making a huge sale in the end. So his that's the thing about Michael, right? Like his weird ways they, they turn out. He's able to connect with people. He is. Say what you want to say about Michael. People like him, not that have to work with him. Yeah. Acquaintances really with people. He is. Say what you want to say about Michael. People like him. Not that have to work with him. Acquaintances really like him. All right, now we're back at the Stanford branch
帕姆就会有麻烦。是啊。我是说，我觉得她后来确实帮他打掩护了。所以也许她一开始想的是，好吧，我会按简告诉我的去做，但后来她觉得过意不去之类的，因为迈克尔整天都像个灾难。是啊。而且他最后还做成了一笔大生意。所以这就是迈克尔的特点，对吧？他那些奇怪的方式，最后都奏效了。他能和人建立联系。他确实能。随你怎么说迈克尔。人们喜欢他，不是说必须和他一起工作的人。是啊。只是点头之交的人。随你怎么说迈克尔。人们喜欢他。不是说必须和他一起工作的人。点头之交的人真的很喜欢他。好了，现在我们回到斯坦福分部。
and Andy, I guess has told Karen he'll try to help her, you know, get that chair back. So he's like, Jim, can you come talk to me over here? And he's like, I can talk to you from here. And he's like, yeah, but could you get up and come over here? And Karen's like, that's all you got? And then Ed as Andy made me laugh so hard when he says,
安迪，我想他已经告诉凯伦他会试着帮她，你知道，把那把椅子拿回来。所以他说，吉姆，你能过来跟我谈谈吗？吉姆说，我在这儿就能跟你谈。安迪说，是啊，但你能站起来过来一下吗？凯伦说，你就这点本事？然后艾德饰演的安迪让我笑得好厉害，当他说，
I'm acting my heart out here. It just made me laugh. I mean, Andy is so bad. He's so transparent. And it just was so funny that he was like, hey, come on. That seemed like an Ed improv to me, but I couldn't check because this storyline isn't in my script. We did have a fan catch at this moment. Marguerite Carter wrote in to say, at around four minutes, 50 seconds, you can see Jim's nameplate
我正在全心全意地表演。这真的让我笑了。我是说，安迪太糟糕了。他太透明了。他那样说真的太搞笑了，嘿，过来吧。那看起来像是艾德的即兴发挥，但我无法核实，因为这段剧情不在我的剧本里。我们确实有粉丝捕捉到了这一刻。玛格丽特·卡特写信来说，在大约4分50秒时，你可以看到吉姆的名牌
on his desk and it says Jim Halpert and underneath it, it says assistant Regional Manager. Marguerite! There you go! Applause! It's official! Well things are about to get real exciting over at the Scranton branch because it is announced it's pretzel day! Oh and Stanley books it out the door. He books it but he grabs his crossword. Well he he knows he knows he's gonna be in line. Yeah, he's planning ahead. He's ready for it. I have a question and this was also a fan catch. Kelly Rue asked,
在他的桌子上，上面写着吉姆·哈尔珀特，下面写着助理区域经理。玛格丽特！就是这样！鼓掌！正式了！好吧，斯克兰顿分部的事情要变得非常令人兴奋了，因为宣布今天是椒盐卷饼日！哦，斯坦利冲出了门。他冲了出去，但他抓住了他的填字游戏。嗯，他知道，他知道他得排队。是啊，他在未雨绸缪。他准备好了。我有一个问题，这也是粉丝捕捉到的。凯利·鲁问，
whose voice makes the announcement about Pretzel Day? And Bailey Aspenson said, is that the voice of Billy Merchant? It is. It's Billy Merchant. Yes, which makes sense because he's the building manager. Yeah, I asked Kent Sabornak because there was a part of me that thought,
是谁的声音宣布了椒盐卷饼日？贝利·阿斯彭森说，那是比利·默钱特的声音吗？是的。是比利·默钱特。没错，这说得通，因为他是大楼经理。是啊，我问了肯特·萨博纳克，因为我心里有一部分在想，
is that Kent's voice? And Kent said no. Kent said they got Marcus York to record that audio for the announcement. Amazing. I love it. I love the attention to detail. I do, too. So now we have the Stanley talking head. That is one of my favorite talking heads and Leslie's delivery of it is so great. He says, I wake up every morning in a bed that's too small, drive my daughter to school that's too expensive. And then I go to work for a job, which I get paid too little.
那是肯特的声音吗？肯特说不是。肯特说他们找了马库斯·约克来录制那个公告音频。太棒了。我喜欢。我喜欢这种对细节的关注。我也喜欢。所以现在是斯坦利的访谈环节。那是我最喜欢的访谈之一，莱斯利的演绎太棒了。他说，我每天早上醒来，睡在太小的床上，开车送女儿去太贵的学校。然后我去上班，做一份薪水太少的工作。
But on pretzel day? Well, I like Pretzel Day. That talking head that appears in the episode is an alternate talking head, Angela. That is not the talking head that was in the shooting draft. It's so perfect, though. I can't imagine anything else. I mean, it's so perfect. It sums up like Stanley. What was it? The original talking head was this.
但在椒盐卷饼日？嗯，我喜欢椒盐卷饼日。那一集里出现的访谈是备选访谈，安吉拉。那不是拍摄初稿里的访谈。但它太完美了。我无法想象别的。我是说，它太完美了。它总结了斯坦利。那是什么？最初的访谈是这样的。
There are four things that I love. My wife, my daughter, Pam Greer, and a hot chewy roll of buttered dough. Pam Greer. All right, fan question from Crystal White. Who came up with the idea of Pretzel Day and were there actually pretzels for the cast to eat on set?
我有四样东西我爱。我的妻子，我的女儿，帕姆·格里尔，还有一个热乎乎、有嚼劲的黄油面团卷。帕姆·格里尔。好了，来自克里斯托·怀特的粉丝提问。是谁想出了椒盐卷饼日的主意，片场真的有椒盐卷饼给演员吃吗？
Thank you so much for your question, Crystal. Okay, so we got a lot of pretzel-related questions. And Jenna, I know you did some digging around and you got the real deal on this. Yes, I found out some good stuff. First off, BJ told me that the inspiration for Pretzel Day goes all the way back to season one. Greg took the writers on these fact-finding visits
非常感谢你的提问，克里斯托。好的，我们收到了很多关于椒盐卷饼的问题。珍娜，我知道你做了一些调查，你得到了关于这件事的真相。是的，我发现了一些好东西。首先，BJ告诉我，椒盐卷饼日的灵感一直追溯到第一季。格雷格带着编剧们进行了这些实地考察，
to real offices so that they could get inspiration for storylines and episodes. I love that. Now, I know that Greg likes to do stuff like this. I know when he was working on King of the Hill, he took all the writers to Austin, Texas, because they were like, okay, you got to know Texas if you're writing about characters that live in Texas.
去真正的办公室，这样他们就能为剧情和剧集寻找灵感。我喜欢这个。我知道格雷格喜欢做这样的事。我知道当他在制作《山丘之王》时，他带着所有编剧去了德克萨斯州的奥斯汀，因为他们当时想，好吧，如果你要写住在德克萨斯州的角色，你就必须了解德克萨斯州。
So I love that Greg is now taking our writers to small businesses. Yes. And lady, he even took them to a paper company. Oh my God. Amazing. Yes. And BJ told me that on one of the days when they went to this office park, they were doing some kind of morale boostingboosting free food giveaway
所以我喜欢格雷格现在带着我们的编剧去小企业考察。是的。而且女士，他甚至带他们去了一家造纸公司。天哪。太棒了。是的，BJ告诉我，在他们去那个办公园区的一天，他们正在做某种提振士气的免费食物赠送活动，
for the employees. It wasn't pretzels. He thinks maybe it was popcorn. But everyone was really excited, and the writers put this idea on a card in the writer's room. And then BJ added the tidbit that Stanley would be the character that looked forward to this free food giveaway all year. I love that. I love that. I love that so much.
给员工们。那不是椒盐卷饼。他觉得可能是爆米花。但每个人都非常兴奋，编剧们把这个想法写在了一张卡片上，放在了编剧室里。然后BJ补充了一个小道消息，说斯坦利会是那个整年都期待这种免费食物赠送的角色。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。我太喜欢这个了。
And it's so relatable. You know, years ago, I worked as an operator, Jenna, and we would have make your own ice cream sundae day, and they would wheel a cart around. You couldn't leave your desk. You had to like stay on calls. It was kind of crazy. But the managers would wheel around this cart,
而且这太有共鸣了。你知道，多年前，我曾做过接线员，珍娜，我们会举办“自制圣代日”，他们会推着小车到处走。你不能离开你的办公桌。你必须保持通话。这有点疯狂。但经理们会推着这辆小车到处走，
and we would get so excited to make our own ice cream sundaes. And I feel like I relate to Stanley on this day. He loved pretzels so much, he looked forward to it so much. Okay. Angela, I feel like we had something similar on our set because we would every once in a while get a coffee cart. Oh, people would lose their minds for that coffee cart. And you would line up outside and you would get to order your gourmet coffee because on the set we really just had that drip coffee because they took our fancy machine away
我们就会非常兴奋地制作自己的圣代。我觉得我在这一天和斯坦利产生了共鸣。他太喜欢椒盐卷饼了，他太期待这一天了。好的，安吉拉，我觉得我们在片场也有类似的情况，因为我们偶尔会有咖啡车。哦，人们会为了那个咖啡车而疯狂。你会排队等候，然后点你的精品咖啡，因为在片场我们真的只有那种滴漏咖啡，因为他们把我们的高级咖啡机拿走了，
for being too loud. Oh yeah, it was too loud. So when we would get a coffee cart and they would come and set up in the parking lot, I mean, the line was around the corner. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. So this is very relatable, and I love this storyline.
因为它太吵了。哦，是的，它太吵了。所以当我们有咖啡车，他们过来在停车场摆摊时，我是说，队伍排到了拐角处。哦，是的。哦，是的。所以这非常有共鸣，我喜欢这个剧情。
I also found out about the pretzels. Oh, where were they from? Kent told me that the pretzels were from Wetzel's Pretzels. Ah! He said that they rented a pretzel cart from a prop house, and Phil Shea decorated it and sort of tricked it out. And they had pretzel toppings, just like in the script. You could have sweet pretzel, maple pretzel. I wasn't in any of the pretzel line scenes, but I do remember that day
我还发现了关于椒盐卷饼的事。哦，它们是从哪儿来的？肯特告诉我，椒盐卷饼来自Wetzel's Pretzels。啊！他说他们从道具公司租了一辆椒盐卷饼车，菲尔·谢装饰了它，并把它改装了一下。他们有椒盐卷饼配料，就像剧本里写的那样。你可以吃甜味椒盐卷饼、枫糖椒盐卷饼。我没有参加任何排队买椒盐卷饼的戏份，但我确实记得那天，
because after the scenes, they put all the extra pretzels over at Crafty. And so Peter had them for everyone. Yeah, I remember that too. Kent told me that they had ordered a hundred pretzels, but we only used a few for the actual scene and that all the leftovers went to Crafty and that between the cast and crew, we ate them all.
因为在拍摄结束后，他们把所有多余的椒盐卷饼都放在了后勤部。所以彼得让每个人都吃了。是啊，我也记得。肯特告诉我，他们订购了一百个椒盐卷饼，但我们实际拍摄只用了几个，剩下的都给了后勤部，在演员和工作人员之间，我们把它们全吃光了。
We did. We had our own pretzel day, guys. We did. We had our own pretzel day. guys. We did. We had our own pretzel day. So now we're in the pretzel line, and Kelly is chatting up Michael. So he's tuning her out, and he's laser focused on his pretzels. And by the way, Phyllis is about to come up to the line, and she's doing that thing where like, oh, I'm just saying hi. She's just saying hi to Bob in line.
我们确实吃了。我们有了自己的椒盐卷饼日，伙计们。我们确实吃了。我们有了自己的椒盐卷饼日。伙计们。我们确实吃了。我们有了自己的椒盐卷饼日。所以现在我们在排队买椒盐卷饼，凯利正在和迈克尔聊天。所以他没理她，他全神贯注于他的椒盐卷饼。顺便说一句，菲利斯快要排到队了，她正在做那种，哦，我只是打个招呼。她只是在排队时跟鲍勃打个招呼。
I'm just saying hi to my to my fella and then I'm gonna sneak in line. Yes, and oh my gosh, Michael and Stanley are not having it. They are booing her. They start booing her. They tell her to get to the back of the line. I mean, the line, I mean. And then they high five. Michael and Stanley high five. I mean, is it the only time in the whole series they high five? They're like friends in this episode. It's a really cute thing.
我只是跟我的男朋友打个招呼，然后我就要插队了。是的，天哪，迈克尔和斯坦利可不吃这一套。他们开始嘘她。他们开始嘘她。他们让她去队尾。我是说，队伍，我是说。然后他们击掌。迈克尔和斯坦利击掌。我是说，这是他们在整部剧里唯一一次击掌吗？他们在这集里就像朋友一样。这真是一件很可爱的事情。
They are friends for a moment, a moment in time. On pretzel day. All right, so back to Squeaky Chair. Karen in Stanford, she is purposely squeaking her chair to annoy Jim. Love me, love me, say that you love me. Yeah. And then Jim tries to get Love Fool stuck in her head. Now Randall pointed out the camera work to me here.
他们有一瞬间是朋友，时光中的一瞬间。在椒盐卷饼日。好了，回到吱吱作响的椅子。斯坦福的凯伦，她故意让她的椅子发出吱吱声来烦吉姆。爱我，爱我，说你爱我。是啊。然后吉姆试图让《Love Fool》这首歌在她脑子里挥之不去。现在兰德尔向我指出了这里的摄影工作。
This is one of the moments where Randall took the camera back because he wanted to do this all in one shot, just changing the focus from Karen to Jim and then pulling back to reveal Andy and again, changing the focus between these three different people. He said he couldn't explain it. He just had to shoot it.
这是兰德尔拿回摄像机的时刻之一，因为他想一镜到底，只是把焦点从凯伦切换到吉姆，然后拉远镜头露出安迪，再次在三个不同的人之间切换焦点。他说他无法解释，他只是必须那样拍。
I love that. I love that he can just be like, I got this, guys. I got it. Let me pick up this camera. Well, on the DVD commentary, they were talking about how much John broke in the scene. They said every time Ed would do a version of, you know, singing the song, John would break. And then they said that Ed started messing with John, trying to sort of like up his game on how he would do it, just to see if he could get John to break. But I just love that. I guess John was kind of a mess
我喜欢这个。我喜欢他能说，我搞定了，伙计们。我搞定了。让我拿起这台摄像机。嗯，在DVD评论中，他们谈到了约翰在这一幕里笑场了多少次。他们说每次艾德唱那首歌时，约翰就会笑场。然后他们说艾德开始捉弄约翰，试图提升他演唱的方式，只是为了看看能不能让约翰笑场。但我就是喜欢这个。我想约翰当时有点乱，
because Ed was just crushing it. All right, so now Stanley, you know, he's getting his pretzel, it's here. Yes, he's at the front of the line. He's moving away. Now there was a line that got deleted here. It's in the script and it's Stanley's pretzel order. A lot of people want to know what was his order. Wait, I don't know what his order was. What was his order? Salty with extra
因为艾德的表现太棒了。好了，现在斯坦利，你知道，他拿到了他的椒盐卷饼，它在这儿。是的，他在队首。他正在走开。现在这里有一句被删掉的台词。它在剧本里，是斯坦利的椒盐卷饼订单。很多人想知道他的订单是什么。等等，我不知道他的订单是什么。他的订单是什么？咸味，加额外
mustard. I did not see that coming. Yeah. Salty with extra mustard is Stanley's pretzel. Okay. Well, when Michael gets to the front of the line, there are just too many toppings for him to choose from. There are 18 different sweet toppings. He's like a child. He is like a child. And I was so impressed with the actor that plays the pretzel guy
芥末。我没料到会这样。是啊。咸味加额外芥末是斯坦利的椒盐卷饼。好的。好吧，当迈克尔排到队首时，对他来说有太多的配料可以选择。有18种不同的甜味配料。他就像个孩子。他就像个孩子。我对扮演椒盐卷饼小哥的演员印象深刻，
because he just rifles off all of those extras like it's nothing and you know he had to memorize all of that. Do you want to hear what they are? There's 18 of them. Yeah. All right they are sweet glaze, cinnamon sugar, chocolate, white chocolate, fudge, M&Ms, caramel dip, mint chip, chocolate chip, marshmallow nuts, toffee nuts, coconuts, peanut butter drizzle, Oreos, sprinkles, cotton candy bits, and powdered sugar. Oh my gosh, and Michael gets the works, oh my God. We had a fan question about this.
因为他就像念经一样念出所有那些配料，就像没什么大不了的，你知道他必须记住所有这些。你想听听它们是什么吗？有18种。好的，它们是甜釉、肉桂糖、巧克力、白巧克力、软糖、M&Ms、焦糖酱、薄荷巧克力豆、巧克力豆、棉花糖、坚果、太妃糖坚果、椰子、花生酱淋酱、奥利奥、糖针、棉花糖碎和糖粉。天哪，迈克尔全都要了，天哪。我们有一个关于这个的粉丝提问。
God in this Chili's wrote in, was the pretzel guy an actor or someone from craft service or someone from the crew? He was an actor and his name was Thomas F. Evans. And he is, he has done a ton of guest appearances on television shows. He's done The Kids Are Alright, Criminal Minds, General Hospital, Days of Our Lives.
God in this Chili's写信问，椒盐卷饼小哥是演员，还是后勤部的人，或者是剧组的人？他是一位演员，他的名字叫托马斯·F·埃文斯。他做过很多电视节目的客串。他演过《孩子们都很好》、《犯罪心理》、《综合医院》、《我们的日子》。
Oh my God, Days of Our Lives. You've probably seen him everywhere. Days of Our Lives, Angela. Well, Thomas, I thought you were fantastic. And I just thought you were the perfect pretzel guy. There's a deleted scene here. Oh yeah, there is. Oh, well, Thomas, I thought you were fantastic, and I just thought you were the perfect pretzel guy. There's a deleted scene here. Oh, yeah, there is.
天哪，《我们的日子》。你可能到处都见过他。《我们的日子》，安吉拉。好吧，托马斯，我觉得你太棒了。我觉得你是完美的椒盐卷饼小哥。这里有一个删减片段。哦，是的，确实有。好吧，托马斯，我觉得你太棒了，我觉得你是完美的椒盐卷饼小哥。这里有一个删减片段。哦，是的，确实有。
Oh, yeah, there is. It's more of the Michael Stanley friendship, and it's kind of too bad that it got cut, because it's a scene in the parking lot of Michael and Stanley eating their pretzels together. They're so happy. Michael says, they taste so good in my mouth. And Stanley goes, that's what she said. I'm so sad that was cut. I am so sad the scene was cut. They shared it. That's what she said. Joke. And then back in the kitchen, there
哦，是的，确实有。那是更多关于迈克尔和斯坦利友谊的内容，被删掉真是太可惜了，因为那是在停车场迈克尔和斯坦利一起吃椒盐卷饼的场景。他们太开心了。迈克尔说，它们在我的嘴里味道真好。斯坦利说，那是她说的。我很难过那段被删了。我很难过那段被删了。他们分享了那个“那是她说的”笑话。然后回到厨房，那里
is one more Stanley pretzel moment that's deleted. And that's in the kitchen. Kevin has gotten his pretzel and he gets distracted looking in the fridge for like a topping and Stanley just swipes the pretzel. That's amazing. He steals Kevin's pretzel. Well, now lady we're on a scene that I have a lot of questions about.
还有一个被删掉的斯坦利吃椒盐卷饼的时刻。那是在厨房。凯文拿到了他的椒盐卷饼，他分心去冰箱里找配料，斯坦利直接顺走了椒盐卷饼。太神奇了。他偷了凯文的椒盐卷饼。好吧，现在女士，我们进入了一个我有很多问题的场景。
Oh, okay. We are in the break room and it's you and Kelly. Yeah. And Kelly is very worried because Ryan has been gone all day and she hasn't heard from him. We know where he is. He's off with Dwight, but she's worried you're eating something that's not a pretzel. It is not a pretzel. I zoomed in on this. Okay, so listen at 10 minutes 57 seconds. I am pretty sure I'm eating popcorn.
哦，好的。我们在休息室，是你和凯利。是的。凯利非常担心，因为瑞安一整天都不见了，她没收到他的消息。我们知道他在哪儿。他和德怀特在一起，但她很担心。你正在吃不是椒盐卷饼的东西。那不是椒盐卷饼。我放大了看。好的，听着，在10分57秒。我很确定我在吃爆米花。
Huh. I think I have a handful of popcorn. I am wondering because sometimes we shot out of order if this was some of the leftover popcorn from the coup. Oh lady, I'm sure they popped you fresh popcorn for this scene. No, I'm just saying maybe we grabbed it from Crafty. Oh, perhaps. Perhaps. Well, we got a fan question also about this scene from Natalie, was this the first Kelly and Angela scene? Well, you know what? I think it's the first time they've sat down together.
嗯。我想我手里有一把爆米花。我在想，因为有时候我们拍摄顺序是乱的，这会不会是政变那集剩下的爆米花？哦，女士，我敢肯定他们为你拍摄这一幕时爆了新鲜的爆米花。不，我只是说也许我们是从后勤部拿的。哦，也许吧。也许吧。好吧，我们还收到了娜塔莉关于这一幕的粉丝提问，这是第一个凯利和安吉拉的场景吗？嗯，你知道吗？我觉得这是她们第一次坐在一起。
I mean, it's definitely a huge Kelly Angela moment. It wasn't that long ago that Kelly got drunk in the Christmas episode and tried to kiss Dwight and Angela Martin. It wasn't that long ago that Kelly got drunk in the Christmas episode and tried to kiss Dwight. And Angela Martin... That's right. I mean, Angela Martin was not having it. No. So it's kind of a big deal that she even tries to comfort Kelly, you know? Yeah. You even pat her hand. You make physical contact. I make physical contact. Then she says that Dwight is weird. And then I say he's not. And then she says he's a freak.
我是说，这绝对是一个巨大的凯利和安吉拉的时刻。不久前凯利在圣诞那集喝醉了，试图亲吻德怀特和安吉拉·马丁。不久前凯利在圣诞那集喝醉了，试图亲吻德怀特。而安吉拉·马丁……没错。我是说，安吉拉·马丁可不吃这一套。不。所以她甚至试图安慰凯利是一件大事，你知道吗？是啊。你甚至拍了拍她的手。你有身体接触。我有身体接触。然后她说德怀特很奇怪。然后我说他不奇怪。然后她说他是个怪胎。
And I'm like, you're a freak. And I storm off. I wrote in my journal that I was really excited to do this scene because Mindy and I never got to do scenes together. But I said that Mindy broke into laughter every single time I glared at her. Mindy was the worst. Mindy was the worst.
我说你才是怪胎。然后我冲了出去。我在日记里写道，我非常兴奋能拍这一幕，因为明迪和我从来没有一起拍过戏。但我说每次我瞪她时，明迪都会笑场。明迪是最糟糕的。明迪是最糟糕的。
I have so many stories coming up of doing scenes with Mindy was the worst. Mindy was the worst. I have so many stories coming up of doing scenes with Mindy where you would say a regular line and she would start laughing. I didn't even say a line. I just looked at her. You just looked at her. Like, really snarky and she'd start laughing. Well, we have a fan catch, Angela, from Jennifer Wells. Guess what you do in this scene, Angela?
我还有很多关于和明迪拍戏的故事，明迪是最糟糕的。明迪是最糟糕的。我还有很多关于和明迪拍戏的故事，你会说一句普通的台词，她就会开始笑。我甚至没说台词。我只是看着她。你只是看着她。就像，真的很刻薄，她就开始笑。好吧，我们有一个粉丝捕捉，安吉拉，来自詹妮弗·威尔斯。猜猜你在这一幕里做了什么，安吉拉？
I know. You get up and you leave, taking only your water, leaving your food behind, again. I should have never made such a big deal when Pam did it, because apparently my character does it all the time. You know why, Angela? Because people do it all the time. People do it all the time. People do it all the time.
我知道。你站起来离开了，只拿了你的水，把你的食物留在了后面，又一次。我不该在帕姆这样做时大惊小怪的，因为显然我的角色一直都在这样做。你知道为什么吗，安吉拉？因为人们一直都在这样做。人们一直都在这样做。人们一直都在这样做。
Do they? You get so mad you leave your food on the table? Yes, you've lost your appetite because you're so angry. That's an indication of how upset you are. You just walk away. If you are in the middle of dinner with someone and you are compelled to walk away from the table, you don't also bring your dish. Although it would be very funny if you did. You'd be like, I'm done talking to you,
是吗？你气得把食物留在桌子上？是的，你因为太生气而失去了胃口。这表明你有多难过。你只是走开了。如果你在和某人吃晚餐时被迫离开桌子，你不会把你的盘子也带走。虽然如果你带走会非常有趣。你会说，我不想再跟你说话了，
but I'm not done eating. I'll eat this in another room. I think comedically, I want to write myself a scene sometime in a show or improvise a moment where I get really furious and I leave the table, but I pack up everything in anger. I pack it all up, but I take it with me. That would be amazing, especially if it took you
但我还没吃完。我会在另一个房间吃这个。我觉得从喜剧角度来看，我想在某个节目里给自己写一个场景，或者即兴发挥一个时刻，我变得非常愤怒，我离开了桌子，但我愤怒地打包了所有东西。我把它们全打包了，但我带走了。那会很棒，特别是如果它花掉你
a very long time to pack it up. And everyone had to just sit there and watch. They have to wait. Yeah, I had to spoon things into a Tupperware. I had to find the lid. I had the wrong lid. We're onto something here. We're onto something.
很长时间来打包。每个人都不得不坐在那里看着。他们必须等待。是啊，我不得不把东西舀进特百惠盒子里。我不得不找盖子。我拿错了盖子。我们发现了一些东西。我们发现了一些东西。
Well, back at Stanford, Andy is now the owner of the squeaky chair. Andy basically would be the Creed. He got the crap chair. He did. He's been creeded. So now we're back at Scranton. Michael's playing music.
好吧，回到斯坦福，安迪现在是那把吱吱作响椅子的主人了。安迪基本上就是克里德。他得到了那把烂椅子。他确实得到了。他被“克里德化”了。所以现在我们回到斯克兰顿。迈克尔在放音乐。
He's got this sugar high going, right? Yeah. And he's playing that song. Hey, right? Yeah. At 13 minutes, 36 seconds, my character is annoyed. She's annoyed at the music. Kevin's into it.
他现在糖分过高，对吧？是啊。他在放那首歌。嘿，对吧？是啊。在13分36秒，我的角色很烦。她对音乐感到厌烦。凯文很投入。
He's thumping his pin. In real life, in real life, Jenna, Preston, our old boom operator, was videoing between scenes, all of us dancing. And he got a video of Creed and I dancing to this in between takes. And it's a little- No way!
他在敲他的笔。在现实生活中，在现实生活中，珍娜，普雷斯顿，我们以前的吊杆操作员，在拍摄间隙录下了我们所有人跳舞的视频。他拍到了克里德和我在这期间跳舞的视频。而且有点——没门！
Yes, it's a little blurry because he said he did it on a flip phone and he texted it to Matt Sohn, our B camera operator who sent it to me. Guys, check Office Ladies Pod Instagram for this amazing behind the scenes video. It's a little blurry. It's a little blurry because it was a flip phone,
是的，有点模糊，因为他说他是用翻盖手机拍的，然后发短信给了马特·索恩，我们的B机操作员，他发给了我。伙计们，去看看Office Ladies Pod的Instagram，看看这个精彩的幕后视频。有点模糊。有点模糊，因为那是翻盖手机，
but Creed and I are dancing our hearts out between takes. But Angela Martin, not so much. Well, when Michael comes out of his office after he's done dancing, he decides to maximize everything and he's talking a mile a minute. And we had a fan question from Claudia Cano, who wants to know,
但克里德和我在这期间跳得非常起劲。但安吉拉·马丁，没那么起劲。好吧，当迈克尔跳完舞从办公室出来时，他决定最大化一切，他说话速度极快。我们收到了克劳迪娅·卡诺的粉丝提问，她想知道，
was that speech when he's talking a million miles an hour improvised? I checked the script. No, like maybe two words were different than what was scripted. Way to go, Steve. Way to go, Steve. Way to go, Steve. And then we had a fan question. A lot of people want to know, Angela. Sarah Quick, Grace and Allie and Sarah and Janelle and Jakey
他说话像机关枪一样的演讲是即兴的吗？我查了剧本。不，可能只有两个词和剧本里写的不一样。干得好，史蒂夫。干得好，史蒂夫。干得好，史蒂夫。然后我们有一个粉丝提问。很多人想知道，安吉拉。莎拉·奎克、格蕾丝和艾莉、莎拉和珍妮尔和杰基
all want to know what topping we would put on our pretzel. I mean, Jenna, I just like the basic. I just like Stanley. I like salty pretzel and give me a little side of some kind of spicy mustard, and I'm happy. Oh, really? This is interesting to me. I am cinnamon sugar.
都想知道我们会在椒盐卷饼上加什么配料。我是说，珍娜，我只喜欢基本的。我只喜欢斯坦利。我喜欢咸味椒盐卷饼，再给我一点那种辣芥末，我就很开心了。哦，真的吗？这对我来说很有趣。我喜欢肉桂糖。
I think it's interesting that you like a salty pretzel and I like a sweet pretzel, but I'm probably the salty person and you're the sweet one. That's not true. Oh, I am way saltier. Please, please. I'm half cremagen. All right. I have a question for you, Jenna. I'm half Cramudgeon. All right. I have a question for you, Jenna.
我觉得有趣的是你喜欢咸味椒盐卷饼，而我喜欢甜味椒盐卷饼，但我可能才是那个咸味的人，而你是那个甜味的人。那不是真的。哦，我比你咸多了。拜托，拜托。我是半个老顽固。好了。我有一个问题要问你，珍娜。我是半个老顽固。好了。我有一个问题要问你，珍娜。
Yeah. On the DVD commentary, BJ says that the line direction where Michael crashes out, you know, he falls asleep on a cush ball. And he really does. He's face planted on his desk. His face is on a cush ball. He said that that was direction written in the script. Do you have that? What does it say exactly? It says in the script, Pam looks through the blinds into Michael's office. It's not good.
是啊。在DVD评论中，BJ说迈克尔崩溃的那段戏，你知道，他睡在了一个靠垫球上。他确实睡着了。他脸朝下趴在桌子上。他的脸在一个靠垫球上。他说那是剧本里写的导演要求。你有那个吗？它到底是怎么说的？剧本里写着，帕姆透过百叶窗看向迈克尔的办公室。情况不妙。
Michael is fast asleep, face on a couch ball. I love that. And then later it notes when it's time to leave for the day, it says, Michael stumbles out of his office squinting with cooch marks on his face. And they put the marks on his face. So someone in here in makeup had to make cooch ball like marks on his face to make his cheek red. I love this moment and I caught a little something.
迈克尔睡得很沉，脸趴在靠垫球上。我喜欢这个。然后后来它提到当一天结束要离开时，它说，迈克尔跌跌撞撞地走出办公室，眯着眼睛，脸上带着靠垫的印记。他们把印记印在了他的脸上。所以这里化妆组的某个人必须在脸上做出像靠垫一样的印记，让他的脸颊变红。我喜欢这一刻，我捕捉到了一点东西。
Now you guys know we have young children. So I am watching every animated movie out there multiple times, and our kids love Despicable Me. They love Despicable Me, they love Minions. We've watched it over and over, and at 16 minutes, 52 seconds, when Michael says, with the jello, I swear I hear Gru from Despicable Me.
现在你们知道我们有年幼的孩子。所以我看了每一部动画电影好几次，我们的孩子喜欢《神偷奶爸》。他们喜欢《神偷奶爸》，他们喜欢小黄人。我们看了又看，在16分52秒，当迈克尔说，带着果冻，我发誓我听到了《神偷奶爸》里的格鲁的声音。
Oh, yes. I will give that to you.icable Me. Oh, yes. I will give that to you. I think it's early, Gru. Listen to it. So now we have a very big scene to end this episode. Yeah. Pam's got her coat on.
哦，是的。我承认这一点。哦，是的。我承认这一点。我觉得那是早期的格鲁。听听看。所以现在我们有一个非常大的场景来结束这一集。是啊。帕姆穿上了外套。
She's done for the day. She's leaving. But her phone rings. You guys, it's Jim. It is Jim. He called the main line because he couldn't remember Kevin's extension. He wants to talk to Kevin about fantasy football. Pam explains she's still at work because Jan told her to do this log about Michael.
她今天的工作结束了。她要走了。但她的电话响了。伙计们，是吉姆。是吉姆。他打了总机，因为他不记得凯文的分机号了。他想和凯文谈谈梦幻足球。帕姆解释说她还在工作，因为简让她做这个关于迈克尔的记录。
And they start to have a conversation. First of all, Jenna, you and John as actors are so fricking good in this scene. This scene wrecked me. Your expression on your face when you realize it's his voice, and the same with John, it's so beautiful. Your conversation is so organic and earnest,
他们开始交谈。首先，珍娜，你和约翰作为演员在这一幕里太棒了。这一幕让我崩溃了。当你意识到是他的声音时，你脸上的表情，约翰也是，太美好了。你们的对话如此自然和真诚，
and oh my God, it gave me all the feels. And I wanna know, was it all scripted or did you guys get to play around a little bit in that? It was mostly scripted, but there was also a lot of improvisation. So I'll kind of, I'll break it down for you, but I wanna say that first of all, this is the first time that John and I had done a scene together,
天哪，它给了我所有的感觉。我想知道，这是全剧本的，还是你们在里面玩了一点即兴？大部分是剧本写的，但也有很多即兴发挥。所以我，我会为你拆解它，但我得说，首先，这是约翰和我第一次一起拍戏，
and we're not even face-to-face, but this is the first time we had performed together in months. Because this was our fifth episode in, but we'd also had our long summer break. When I was watching this scene, oh my gosh, all of this sense memory came back to me. And I remember what it was like to shoot this. We spent hours shooting this scene.
我们甚至不是面对面，但这是我们几个月来第一次一起表演。因为这是我们的第五集，但我们也度过了漫长的暑假。当我观看这一幕时，天哪，所有的感官记忆都回到了我身上。我记得拍摄这一幕是什么感觉。我们花了几个小时拍摄这一幕。
Let me say too, we had a lot of people write in. A lot of people, I will say them. Anna, Beatrice, Alexandra, Iva, Lee, Gracie, Nina, they all want to know if John and I were actually talking on the phone during our conversation. Because we've talked a lot about how usually if you're talking on the phone to someone, they're not really there. You're just pretending. Yes. This felt like you were, Jenna. We were.
我也得说，我们收到了很多人的来信。很多人，我会说出他们的名字。安娜、比阿特丽斯、亚历山德拉、伊娃、李、格蕾丝、尼娜，她们都想知道约翰和我当时在对话时是否真的在通电话。因为我们谈过很多次，通常如果你在和某人通电话，他们并不真的在那里。你只是在假装。是的。这感觉就像你们在，珍娜。我们确实在。
Were you? Yes. You were. We were like you were Jenna. We were. Were you? Yes. You were. We were. Oh my god. Okay, so you're reacting to each other in real time. You heard each other's voices in real time. This was really rare. We only did this a couple of times on our set, but here's what happened. Randall told me that he requested that we be able to hear one another, but not just that, he wanted to shoot both sides of the conversation at the same time. And this was really complicated because the Stanford set was in one building, and then there was a huge parking lot,
你们在吗？是的。你们在。我们就像你一样，珍娜。我们确实在。你们在吗？是的。你们在。我们确实在。天哪。好的，所以你们在实时回应对方。你们实时听到了对方的声音。这真的很罕见。我们在片场只做了几次，但发生了什么事。兰德尔告诉我，他要求我们能够听到对方，不仅如此，他还想同时拍摄对话的两边。这真的很复杂，因为斯坦福的片场在一个大楼里，然后有一个巨大的停车场，
and then the Scranton set was in another building. And he said he thinks that it was his inexperience as a director that led him to making this, what he realized is now was like a very bold, complicated request. Logistically, this was very hard to do, and he didn't realize that. No, he was like, hey, listen, when we do that scene with Jim and Pam, I'm gonna want to be able to like have a camera on each of them,
然后斯克兰顿的片场在另一个大楼里。他说他认为是他作为导演的经验不足导致他做出了这个，他现在意识到是一个非常大胆、复杂的请求。从后勤上讲，这很难做到，他当时没意识到。不，他当时想，嘿，听着，当我们拍吉姆和帕姆的那场戏时，我会想要能够让摄像机对着他们每个人，
and I want them to be able to hear each other on the phone. And he says now, looking back, he realizes what an insane request that was, because here's what had to happen. Kent told me that NBC Universal IT came out, and first they had to hook up the phone lines from these two buildings so that John and I could talk to one another.
而且我希望他们能在电话里听到对方。他现在回想起来，意识到这是一个多么疯狂的请求，因为必须发生以下事情。肯特告诉我，NBC环球的IT部门来了，首先他们必须连接这两个大楼的电话线，这样约翰和我才能互相交谈。
He said that they put Video Village, which is where the video feed goes. It's a little tent with video monitors and each camera goes into a different monitor so that the director can sit and see what the cameras are seeing. They had to build that in the middle of the two stages in a parking lot. They had to run that in the middle of the two stages in a parking lot. They had to run phone lines, they had to build a tent full of monitors and make sure they had enough cable that those monitors could be active and working. Yes. Oh my god.
他说他们建立了“视频村”，也就是视频信号去的地方。那是一个带有视频监视器的小帐篷，每个摄像机都进入不同的监视器，这样导演就可以坐着看摄像机看到的东西。他们必须在两个舞台中间的停车场建立那个。他们必须在两个舞台中间的停车场运行那个。他们必须运行电话线，他们必须建立一个装满监视器的帐篷，并确保他们有足够的电缆，让那些监视器能够激活并工作。是的。天哪。
Yes. Because the cable goes from the monitor through the parking lot, through the building, all the way to the camera. Oh my gosh. So the director can see what was happening. Then they recorded audio on three different lines. They had a boom operator in with me. They had a boom operator in with John.
是的。因为电缆从监视器穿过停车场，穿过大楼，一直到摄像机。天哪。所以导演可以看到发生了什么。然后他们在三条不同的线路上录制了音频。他们有一个吊杆操作员和我在一起。他们有一个吊杆操作员和约翰在一起。
And then they were able to record the actual phone conversation through the phone line. Oh my gosh. Insane, right? That's very technically difficult. But the result is beautiful. And it made all the difference for John and I to be able to hear one another and to be able to really talk.
然后他们能够通过电话线录制实际的电话对话。天哪。太疯狂了，对吧？这在技术上非常困难。但结果很美。约翰和我能够听到对方，能够真正交谈，这产生了所有的不同。
One of the things I love about your conversation, which made it feel so real, is that you guys, you're just jumping all around on all these different subjects, just having this conversation, because you haven't talked to each other in so long. It's like all your thoughts are coming out. Yes, and in the script, there were these little time jumps. So, and the way BJ wrote it out was so cool too,
关于你们的对话，我喜欢的一点是，它让它感觉如此真实，是因为你们，你们只是在所有这些不同的主题上跳来跳去，只是在进行这场对话，因为你们已经很久没有交谈了。就像你们所有的想法都涌出来了。是的，在剧本里，有这些小的时间跳跃。所以，BJ写出来的方式也很酷，
because he would write stage direction that were things like, Pam lingers wondering if she should have a seat. Will this phone call go on much longer? So it's like, he gave me these things to play out. And then it would time cut to a new subject. So it's like, we start talking about typing, but then when we time cut to the 28 days,
因为他会写舞台指示，比如，帕姆徘徊着，想知道她是否应该坐下。这个电话还会持续很久吗？所以就像，他给了我这些东西来演绎。然后它会时间剪辑到一个新的主题。所以就像，我们开始谈论打字，但当我们时间剪辑到《28天后》
28 days later conversation, it says Pam is now seated. And then, you know, it gave us direction about our body language so that you see the passage of time that has happened in this conversation. You get the sense that I feel like this was like a 40 minute conversation. And then, of course, it ends so awkwardly. So abruptly and weird.
《28天后》的对话时，它说帕姆现在坐下了。然后，你知道，它给了我们关于肢体语言的指示，这样你就能看到在这场对话中发生的时间流逝。你感觉到我觉得这就像一场40分钟的对话。然后，当然，它结束得如此尴尬。如此突然和奇怪。
Oh. I know. And it breaks your heart. It breaks your heart. But that's perfect, too. It's perfect, too, that they had this moment, but then it got weird. So, you know, they're not out of the woods here. They just got to hear each other's voice. And it felt like home for a little bit. But it was everything. It was everything. I loved it. I loved it. It just completely wrecked me, but you guys always wrecked me. The Jim and Pam stuff always gets me. Oh, man. I think more than any relationship on the show,
哦。我知道。它让你心碎。它让你心碎。但这也很完美。他们有这一刻，但后来变得奇怪了，这也很完美。所以，你知道，他们还没脱离困境。他们只是听到了对方的声音。这感觉就像家一样，持续了一小会儿。但这代表了一切。这代表了一切。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。它完全让我崩溃了，但你们总是让我崩溃。吉姆和帕姆的东西总是让我感动。哦，伙计。我觉得比剧中的任何关系都多，
it's the one that gets me every time. But I guess, you know, I'm not alone because that's everybody. All right, so I think we should take a break now. And when we come back, we are going to be talking with BJ Novak and Rainn Wilson. Oh my gosh, we're gonna talk all things initiation. So come on back. ["The Daily Show Theme"]
这是每次都让我感动的那个。但我猜，你知道，我并不孤单，因为那是每个人。好了，我想我们现在应该休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将和BJ·诺瓦克和雷恩·威尔逊交谈。天哪，我们要谈谈关于入会的一切。所以回来吧。["The Daily Show Theme"]
Spring is here, and you can now get almost anything you need delivered with Uber Eats. What do we mean by almost? You can't get a Well Groom lawn delivered, but you can get chicken Parmesan delivered. Sunshine? No. Some wine? Yes. Get almost, almost anything delivered with Uber Eats. Order now.
春天来了，你现在几乎可以通过Uber Eats配送任何你需要的东西。我们说的“几乎”是什么意思？你不能配送修剪好的草坪，但你可以配送鸡肉帕尔马干酪。阳光？不。一些葡萄酒？是的。通过Uber Eats配送几乎、几乎任何东西。现在下单。
Alcohol in select markets. See app for details. The GMC employee pricing event is on now. Get a big cash purchase discount of up to $12,300 on the 2025 GMC Sierra 1500 and the 2025 Sierra HD. With Sierra 1500's the 2025 Sierra HD. With Sierra 1500's premium interior and advanced tech, or Sierra HD's impressive power and capability, you'll have everything you need to get from work
酒精在特定市场。详情请见应用程序。GMC员工定价活动正在进行中。在2025款GMC Sierra 1500和2025款Sierra HD上获得高达12,300美元的大额现金购买折扣。凭借Sierra 1500的2025款Sierra HD。凭借Sierra 1500的优质内饰和先进技术，或Sierra HD令人印象深刻的动力和能力，你将拥有本季从工作
to play with confidence this season. Hurry in, employee pricing is on for a limited time. Visit your local GMC dealer for details. Introducing TurboTax Business, a brand new way to file your own T2 return, all while getting help from an expert who actually knows small businesses. Got a tattoo studio, toy store, tiny but mighty taco stand? We've got someone who gets small business taxes
到娱乐所需的一切，充满自信。赶快行动，员工定价限时提供。访问当地GMC经销商了解详情。隆重推出TurboTax Business，一种申报你自己的T2报税表的全新方式，同时获得真正了解小企业的专家的帮助。有纹身工作室、玩具店、虽小但强大的塔可摊？我们有了解小企业税收的人
inside and out. Experts are standing by to help and review while you file, so you know your return's done right. Intuit TurboTax Business, new from TurboTax Canada. Some regional exclusions apply. Learn more at TurboTax.ca business tax. Hey, everybody, we're back and guess who's with us. It's BJ Novak and Rainn Wilson.
里里外外。专家随时待命，在你申报时提供帮助和审查，所以你知道你的报税表做得对。Intuit TurboTax Business，来自TurboTax Canada的新产品。适用一些地区排除条款。在TurboTax.ca商业税了解更多。嘿，大家好，我们回来了，猜猜谁和我们在一起。是BJ·诺瓦克和雷恩·威尔逊。
Hey, you guys. Hey, office gentlemen and ladies. Hi. Welcome, office gentlemen, office humans, office people, office people. Oh, boy. Well, this is already fun. All right, BJ, let's get started. You wrote this episode, you perform in it, obviously, but you wrote it. Can you tell us a little bit about writing it? Sure, as as I'm sure has been established on the show and or elsewhere, you know, the way that a writer's room works is
嘿，你们好。嘿，办公室的绅士和女士们。嗨。欢迎，办公室绅士，办公室人类，办公室的人，办公室的人。哦，天哪。好吧，这已经很有趣了。好了，BJ，让我们开始吧。你写了这一集，你显然在里面表演，但你写了它。你能告诉我们一点关于写它的事吗？当然，正如我相信在节目或其他地方已经确定的那样，你知道，编剧室的工作方式是
it's very collective. And so while I wrote the episode in the sense that I was the point person on the episode, I wrote the first draft, I cared the most about it. I likely did more writing than anyone else on this particular one. That's sort of the way the taking turns process works of the writers room. So there's plenty of things, ideas and lines and stuff that I didn't write. And there's a lot I don't remember, but my memory of this time is very sporadic. Sometimes I remember things in incredible detail and there are entire plot lines in episodes I wrote that I just barely, barely recall at all.
这非常具有集体性。所以虽然我写了这一集，意思是我负责这一集，我写了初稿，我最关心它。在这个特定的一集中，我写的可能比任何人都多。这就是编剧室轮流工作的方式。所以有很多东西、想法和台词之类的不是我写的。而且我记不清很多事情，我对这段时间的记忆非常零碎。有时我能极其详细地记得一些事情，而我写的剧集里有整条情节线我几乎完全记不起来了。
So this might be a very spotty recollection. But yes, I did write this one. That was a fantastic little monologue. And the whole time I just kept thinking, is the Starship Enterprise trying to summon BJ up to the ship? Did you guys hear that background? No is ringing. Is your laundry done? That's the sound my washing machine mate. Yeah.
所以这可能是一个非常模糊的回忆。但是的，我确实写了这一集。那是一段很棒的小独白。整个过程中我一直在想，星际迷航的企业号是在试图把BJ传送到飞船上吗？你们听到那个背景音了吗？不，那是铃声。你的衣服洗好了吗？那是我洗衣机的声音，伙计。是的。
Should we do it again? No, no, I think we should know that I think we should use all this. I think this is all gold. This is all gold because it's like, you know what we're zooming and shit me cray cray up in here with the things ringing in the background. See, that's a great monologue too, Rain. We're both articulate today. You guys, you showed up, you showed up.
我们要重来一遍吗？不，不，我觉得我们应该知道，我觉得我们应该用上所有这些。我觉得这些都是金子。这些都是金子，因为就像，你知道我们在缩放，背景里有东西在响，我简直要疯了。看，那也是一段很棒的独白，雷恩。我们今天都很能言善辩。你们，你们出现了，你们出现了。
And did we ever? There was some spaceship attempting to beam someone up in the background of that monologue. But surely there were chunks of it you wrote. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. Even central ideas in the script in which you said, I would really like to write this, I connect with this. And so it was assigned to you because you had a feel
我们真的出现过吗？那段独白背景里确实有某种宇宙飞船试图把人传送上去。但肯定有你写的部分。哦，是的，是的，是的。即使是剧本中的核心思想，你说过，我真的很想写这个，我和它有共鸣。所以它被分配给了你，因为你有一种感觉
for where you wanted the episode to go. Yeah, in this case, well, in this case, I think it was a combination of Greg Daniels and Mike Schurr who came up with or spearheaded the idea. Maybe I said, Dwight should initiate Ryan and they they ran with it a bit. I remember it being assigned to me because I was Ryan, as opposed to because I was obsessed with the story. But there can be very arbitrary reasons that you're assigned an episode in the writer's room. It can be, it's very often because you came up with the original idea. It's often just, it's your turn. You know, we're on episode seven and you're the writer who hasn't gotten one in five episodes. And in this case, I think it was, it was, oh, you're Ryan, it's around your
关于你想让这一集走向何方。是的，在这种情况下，嗯，在这种情况下，我认为是格雷格·丹尼尔斯和迈克·舒尔共同提出了这个想法，或者说是他们带头的。也许我说过，德怀特应该引导瑞安，他们就顺着这个想法做了一些发挥。我记得它被分配给我，是因为我是瑞安，而不是因为我沉迷于这个故事。但在编剧室里，分配剧集的原因可能非常随意。这可能是，通常是因为你提出了最初的想法。通常只是，轮到你了。你知道，我们正在拍第七集，而你是过去五集里还没写过剧本的编剧。在这种情况下，我想是，是，哦，你是瑞安，轮到
turn. Perfect. I did like it. And I thought that Dwight initiates Ryan with, you know, those three words, it's just an amazing log line. Just so rich. You know, one of them, sometimes we'd spend forever pitching stories. Now I'm just on a writer's room tangent because this is my first time on Office Ladies. But we were about to leave, it was late. We had all given these paragraph long pitches. And I guess this was really, you know, I imagine the other writers might have been mad at this, but after all of this, I just, we were about to leave,
你了。太完美了。我确实喜欢它。而且我认为德怀特用那三个词引导瑞安，这真是一个了不起的标语。太丰富了。你知道，其中一个，有时我们会花很长时间推销故事。现在我只是在编剧室里跑题了，因为这是我第一次上《办公室女士》。但我们正要离开，天已经晚了。我们都给出了这些长段落的推销。我想这真的是，你知道，我想其他编剧可能对此很生气，但在所有这些之后，我只是，我们正要离开，
and I said, Greg, I got a two word pitch, booze cruise. And he said, we're doing it. So sometimes it's the shortest pitch that says the most. And by the way, that was my last contribution to Booz Groups. But initiation, Dwight initiates Ryan, you know, there's just so much you can picture. Well, I love how this storyline begins. And we actually asked Sam to pull the audio clip so we could all listen to it. This is you guys are in the car. Ryan thinks he's driving to a sales meeting.
我说，格雷格，我有一个两个词的推销，酒水巡游。他说，我们做吧。所以有时最短的推销表达了最多的意思。顺便说一句，那是我对酒水巡游的最后贡献。但是引导，德怀特引导瑞安，你知道，你可以想象的东西太多了。嗯，我喜欢这个故事情节的开始方式。我们实际上让萨姆提取了音频片段，这样我们都可以听听。这是你们在车里。瑞安以为他正开车去参加销售会议。
But Dwight has driven him into the middle of a beet field. Let's listen to the clip. So where's the sales office? When you are ready to see the sales office, the sales office will present itself to you. Your journey begins now. I love you. Your journey begins now. I love it. Your journey begins now.
但德怀特把他开到了甜菜田中间。让我们听听这段片段。那么销售办公室在哪里？当你准备好看到销售办公室时，销售办公室就会出现在你面前。你的旅程现在开始。我爱你。你的旅程现在开始。我喜欢它。你的旅程现在开始。
And the look on your face, BJ, when he, yeah, you have a lot of really good looks. Well, this is why I think Rain and I were a very good pairing because I am such a reactor and Rain is such a generator. Do you think that's fair in sort of our improv styles in the office? I think so. I think that's out.
还有你脸上的表情，BJ，当他，是的，你有很多非常好的表情。嗯，这就是为什么我认为雷恩和我是一对很好的搭档，因为我是个反应者，而雷恩是个生成者。你认为这在我们在办公室的即兴表演风格中公平吗？我想是的。我想那是。
Yeah. The setup to this was fantastic too. Like, are you excited? Are you really excited? Are you super duper excited? And Ryan's like, I'm a little excited. And Dwight's like, I'm incredibly excited. And so to know that Dwight has a combination
是的。这段的铺垫也很棒。比如，你兴奋吗？你真的很兴奋吗？你超级无敌兴奋吗？瑞安说，我有点兴奋。德怀特说，我非常兴奋。所以知道德怀特结合了
of Jedi Master and Kung Fu, the television show from the 70s with David Carradine and any other movies, Karate Kid, Wax on Wax off, anything he's in horror films about initiations, like are all jumbled in his head, like, like a popcorn machine. And the the excitement there from is, is a lot of fun to watch. Well, it's funny you mentioned that rain, because I do think that all of his experience with initiation is based on fictional
绝地大师和70年代大卫·卡拉丁主演的电视剧《功夫》，以及任何其他电影，比如《龙威小子》，打蜡擦蜡，任何他看过的关于引导的恐怖电影，就像在爆米花机里一样在他脑子里乱成一团。而由此产生的兴奋感，看起来非常有趣。嗯，你提到这一点很有趣，雷恩，因为我确实认为他所有关于引导的经验都基于他看过的虚构
things that he's watched. Because I have the script for this and there are some deleted talking heads that you have rain where you talk about how very often like guys from a fraternity rent out your farm for activities and every year they get a goat and you would love to know what they do with that goat. So it's like, you have no, like that got deleted.
事物。因为我有这一集的剧本，而且有一些被删减的谈话片段，雷恩，你谈到兄弟会的家伙经常租你的农场进行活动，每年他们都会弄一只山羊，你很想知道他们用那只山羊做什么。所以就像，你没有，就像那段被删了。
It's unfortunate, but you know, that happens sometimes, but it's true. I think Dwight's only frame of reference are things he's watched. He's never actually participated in an initiation, unlike Ryan who says he was in a fraternity in college and he's very familiar with this.
这很不幸，但你知道，有时会发生这种情况，但这是真的。我认为德怀特的唯一参考框架是他看过的东西。他从未真正参与过引导，不像瑞安，他说他在大学时参加过兄弟会，他对这个非常熟悉。
Yeah. Yeah. Let's go to the beat field. Dwight makes Ryan plant a seed in the ground. And then we have this line. Just as you have planted a seed in the ground, I'm going to plant my seed in you. Rain, I think that was an improvisation. I think it was an improvisation? I think it was. I think I improvised that and was, you know, tentatively and excitedly
是的。是的。让我们去甜菜田。德怀特让瑞安在地里种下一颗种子。然后我们有了这句台词。正如你在地里种下了一颗种子，我也要在我身上种下我的种子。雷恩，我想那是即兴创作。我想那是即兴创作吗？我想是的。我想我即兴创作了那句，并且，你知道，试探性地且兴奋地
went to BJ like, can we keep that and BJ was like, yes, we can keep that. Oh, it was a killer. It was a killer improv. I remember it so vividly. And you know, this is and I did, you know, I said, I don't think you know what you're saying, which is, which was perfect. It was perfect. I hardly mean to say it was equivalent all in its quality. All I mean to say is that was a very good rain generating comedy and me being a very good backboard for it as a reactor.
走向BJ说，我们可以保留那个吗？BJ说，是的，我们可以保留那个。哦，那真是太棒了。那是一个杀手级的即兴表演。我记得非常清楚。你知道，这是，我确实，你知道，我说，我不认为你知道你在说什么，这，这很完美。这很完美。我并不是说它的质量是等同的。我只是想说，那是雷恩生成喜剧的一个非常好的例子，而我作为一个反应者，是它非常好的背景板。
You know, I think the generator is a way more valuable improviser to have on a show, but it's a very good team. But I very vividly remember Rain improvising that line because with great respect, I considered it a dunk on me as the writer that he would just on the spot come up with a line that was probably better than any single line in the script. I had worked so hard on. So I mean it. You're very you're very kind. That's how I remembered it. I
你知道，我认为生成者是节目中更有价值的即兴表演者，但这是一个很好的团队。但我非常清楚地记得雷恩即兴创作了那句台词，因为出于极大的尊重，我把它看作是对我作为编剧的一种打击，他竟然能当场想出一句可能比我辛苦写出的剧本里的任何一句台词都好的台词。所以我说的是真的。你非常，你非常善良。我是这样记得的。我
remembered it. Here's what I want to say about working in the office and why it was such a magical time and place to work under the tutelage of Greg Daniels because because we were allowed to do that and to bring our ideas. And at the end of the day, um, not all the writers were, some of the writers were like, no, I want to just stick to the lines in the script in the editing room. But in the editing room, for the most part, especially if Greg and Dave, who was our chief editor were in there, they would just take what's funniest. Then they would just, Lee, I don't care what's on the page, they would just take what's funniest. Then they would just,
记得。关于在办公室工作，以及为什么在格雷格·丹尼尔斯的指导下工作是一个如此神奇的时间和地点，我想说的是，因为我们被允许这样做，并带来我们的想法。归根结底，嗯，并不是所有的编剧都这样，有些编剧是，不，我只想在剪辑室里坚持剧本里的台词。但在剪辑室里，在大多数情况下，特别是如果格雷格和我们的首席剪辑师戴夫在里面，他们只会采用最有趣的东西。然后他们只会，李，我不在乎页面上写了什么，他们只会采用最有趣的东西。然后他们只会，
Lee, I don't care what's on the page. I don't care what's supposed to be there. We're just going to take what's funniest and works the best and what was captured on the camera and make the episode about that. So it was this really nice feeling like, you know, you could improvise all you wanted. It was probably going to get cut. But if you improvised and it added something and elevated it, it was probably going to make it. So everyone felt like they were a valuable contributor. And believe me, I've been on a lot of TV sets since then and before then. And that's just not the case.
李，我不在乎页面上写了什么。我不在乎应该有什么。我们只会采用最有趣、效果最好、摄像机捕捉到的东西，并以此为基础制作这一集。所以这是一种非常好的感觉，你知道，你可以随心所欲地即兴发挥。它很可能会被剪掉。但如果你即兴发挥，它增加了一些东西并提升了它，它很可能会被保留下来。所以每个人都觉得他们是一个有价值的贡献者。相信我，从那以后和那之前，我参加过很多电视节目拍摄。事实并非如此。
I got totally spoiled working with Greg, because Greg truly wanted my stories. He wanted my ideas. He loved to pepper me with questions about what my life was like when I was really a receptionist. And those little things would find their way into the show. And it made me feel like, oh, this is what it is. This is my first TV show. I didn't know any different.
和格雷格一起工作让我完全被宠坏了，因为格雷格真的想要我的故事。他想要我的想法。他喜欢向我抛出关于我真正做接待员时生活是什么样的问题。那些小事会进入节目。这让我觉得，哦，原来是这样。这是我的第一个电视节目。我不知道有什么不同。
So jobs that I've had since, I will go into the writers' offices and out with my bright ideas and my stories and my lore. And I realized quickly that most showrunners and writers are like, stop talking. Not interested. Please leave my office. I'm trying to write dialogue for you." And I was like, aw, wah-wah. I have to tell you guys, this is sort of an embarrassing moment. After the office ended, I did a multicam for TBS called Your Family or Mine. And I'd never done a multicam before, really like that. And in between setups, I ran over to the writers and they were really nice, but I ran over to them and I'm like, guys, I have a few pitches.
所以从那以后的工作中，我会带着我聪明的想法、故事和知识走进编剧办公室。我很快意识到大多数剧集主管和编剧都是，别说了。没兴趣。请离开我的办公室。我正试图为你写对话。" 我当时想，哎呀，哇哇。我必须告诉你们，这是一个有点尴尬的时刻。办公室结束后，我为TBS做了一个多机位节目，叫《你的家人还是我的》。我以前从未真正做过那样的多机位。在设置间隙，我跑到编剧那里，他们人很好，但我跑到他们那里说，伙计们，我有几个推销。
And they were like, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, what? Like, we're not doing any pitches. Like that's, we'll come to you if we have an idea. We have an audience loaded in. You don't just, Kinsey get to come over here on the fly and be like, hey, I got a pitch. Like, it's like, no. BJ, as a writer and show runner
他们说，对不起，对不起，什么？就像，我们不做任何推销。就像那是，如果我们有想法，我们会来找你。我们已经加载了观众。你不能，金西，就这样跑过来，说，嘿，我有一个推销。就像，不。BJ，作为一名编剧和剧集主管
who has gone on to do more things after the office, and, you know, like you created your own show. What is it? How do you run your shows? Do you have you borrowed from Greg's way? Is it a mix? Well, I'm very, I'm very early in show running a couple of shows that I'm just getting off the ground. So I don't actually have much experience as a show runner a little. But just to speak about Greg's view towards actors again, which I very much sort of took from him or learned from him and connected to, he,
在办公室之后做了更多事情，而且，你知道，就像你创作了自己的节目。是什么？你是怎么管理你的节目的？你借鉴了格雷格的方式吗？这是一个混合体吗？嗯，我在管理我刚起步的几个节目方面还很早。所以我实际上没有太多作为剧集主管的经验，一点点。但再次谈到格雷格对演员的看法，我非常从他那里借鉴或向他学习并与之联系，他，
there are a lot of reasons why I think he wanted me and Mindy and Paul Lieberstein and Mike Schur to play Moe's, which we can totally get into because there's a lot of fun psychology at play there as well as creativity. And the fact that in the early days of the pilot, Greg would talk about Angela and Oscar in particular, as people he knew would be good and he didn't know yet what the characters were exactly because he trusted them as improvisers. I think that having people, you know, some ambassadors go back and forth between the writers room and set teaches you as writers to trust the actor's instincts, because I know this is a stand-up too, you performing it, you are the last line of defense.
我认为他想让我、明迪、保罗·利伯斯坦和迈克·舒尔扮演莫斯的原因有很多，我们可以完全深入探讨，因为那里有很多有趣的心理学以及创造力。而且在试播集的早期，格雷格会特别谈到安吉拉和奥斯卡，作为他知道会表现出色的人，他当时还不知道角色到底是什么，因为他信任他们作为即兴表演者。我认为让一些大使在编剧室和片场之间来回走动，会教导你们作为编剧去信任演员的直觉，因为我知道这也是单口喜剧，你表演它，你是最后一道防线。
You are the soldier on the front line. And you know if there are bullets coming at you or if you're firing on all cylinders or whatever, you'd know in your body. So if you know something isn't working or after a little while, you just know it's not going to work. You're going to feel fake. It's not going to be your character. And I think that when you know that and you tell that to writers, if the writer has no experience with it, they think you're being a diva. They think you just want a better line or you want to be important. They don't realize that you might know better than them because you're actually they're doing it. And often you write a line, you know, the more experience I had on set on the show, the more I knew that, the more I
你是前线的士兵。你知道是否有子弹向你射来，或者你是否火力全开，无论如何，你会在身体里感觉到。所以如果你知道有什么不对劲，或者过了一会儿，你只是知道它行不通。你会觉得虚假。那不会是你的角色。我认为当你了解这一点并告诉编剧时，如果编剧没有经验，他们会认为你在耍大牌。他们认为你只是想要更好的台词或者你想变得重要。他们没有意识到你可能比他们更了解，因为你实际上是在做这件事。而且通常你写了一句台词，你知道，我在节目片场经验越丰富，我就越知道这一点，我就越
knew to listen to the actors. I think Greg knew that too. That was so beautifully said. I know he needs his own podcasting, a podcast about TV writing for TV writers. Well, I was hoping that the spaceship sound came in. So you guys would wonder like, where is he getting this? I don't know, the whole time you were talking, I was just kind of like, ah,
知道要听取演员的意见。我想格雷格也知道这一点。那说得太美了。我知道他需要自己的播客，一个关于电视写作的播客，给电视编剧看的。嗯，我本来希望宇宙飞船的声音能进来。这样你们就会想，他从哪里得到这个的？我不知道，你说话的整个过程中，我只是有点像，啊，
cause I thought it was so well said. Yeah. Great. I think we were very fortunate that our show was a creative collaboration, and we definitely feel that moving forward when it's not the case. Greg would often say that the reason that he went to us so much was because he really trusted us,
因为我觉得你说得太好了。是的。太棒了。我认为我们非常幸运，我们的节目是一个创造性的合作，当我们向前迈进时，如果不是这种情况，我们肯定会感觉到。格雷格经常说，他之所以如此频繁地找我们，是因为他真的很信任我们，
and that was part of the audition process for him, which was hiring actors that he really trusted us. And that was part of the audition process for him, which was hiring actors that he felt he could go to in this way. You know what I mean? It's like, I mean, to be fair, like not every actor has great ideas. I don't know.
那是他试镜过程的一部分，也就是雇佣他真正信任的演员。那是他试镜过程的一部分，也就是雇佣他觉得可以用这种方式对待的演员。你知道我的意思吗？我的意思是，公平地说，并不是每个演员都有很棒的想法。我不知道。
Like it doesn't matter. Not every actor is aligned creatively with what we were doing on this show. Not every actor is aligned creatively with what we were doing on this show. Not every actor is looking for a line that resonates deep within them, is personal, is the character. Sometimes they just want a line they think would be cool or something, right? Yeah.
就像这不重要。并不是每个演员在创造上都与我们在节目中所做的一致。并不是每个演员在创造上都与我们在节目中所做的一致。并不是每个演员都在寻找一句能引起他们内心深处共鸣、是个人的、是角色的台词。有时他们只是想要一句他们认为会很酷的台词之类的，对吧？是的。
And that might not work for a show like ours. I did have a pitch that I tried four or five times to pitch to Paul and Greg because Paul Lieberstein took over for a couple seasons there as showrunner. And it was, it never happened. And I just thought, oh my God, you're missing the opportunity of your lives, which is,
那可能不适合像我们这样的节目。我确实有一个推销，我尝试了四五次向保罗和格雷格推销，因为保罗·利伯斯坦接手了几季的剧集主管。而且，它从未发生过。我只是想，哦，天哪，你们错过了生命中的机会，那就是，
and it's pretty preposterous when I look back on it now, but I was convinced it would have been great, which is like early on, there's just some scenes and it's Michael and Dwight and Jim and Pam and we're all blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And then it pans over to Creed and Creed is like looks to the camera and Creed goes, psst, psst, psst, hey buddy.
当我回首往事时，这很荒谬，但我确信那会很棒，那就是在早期，有一些场景，是迈克尔、德怀特、吉姆和帕姆，我们都在巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉。然后镜头转向克里德，克里德看着镜头，克里德说，嘘，嘘，嘘，嘿伙计。
And the camera's like looking, it's like, come on, come on, come with me. And the camera crew followsed out and they get in the entire episode. Creed his life is taking them o of creed. I mean, he goes living in an abandoned, yo and he's got pet raccoons,
镜头就像在看，就像，来吧，来吧，跟我来。摄像组跟着他出去了，他们得到了整集。克里德，他的生活正在带他们离开克里德。我的意思是，他住在一个废弃的，哟，他有宠物浣熊，
and then he goes and he robs a liquor store, and he's like, he's just like, come on. And the whole thing is like, almost dialogue free, you're just following greed through this insane maze. And I feel like you've earned that. If you're on episode 137, you've earned an episode where you can do something like that, but it didn't happen.
然后他去抢劫了一家酒类商店，他就像，他只是像，来吧。整个事情就像，几乎没有对话，你只是跟着克里德穿过这个疯狂的迷宫。我觉得你赢得了那个。如果你在第137集，你赢得了一集你可以做这样的事情，但它没有发生。
I found something similar with Threat Level Midnight where I don't know if it was right or wrong. And I think we got a lot of good stuff from telling the frame story. But what I wanted was just drop Threat Level Midnight on the audience. And I think there was a traditional and very, very likely correct,
我在《威胁等级午夜》中发现了类似的情况，我不知道它是对还是错。我认为我们通过讲述框架故事得到了很多好东西。但我想要的是直接把《威胁等级午夜》扔给观众。我认为有一个传统的，而且非常，非常可能是正确的，
but a traditional view of, you don't, we don't do one-off experiments on this show. You know, we tell the story. And there's an A and a B and a C story and you've got to stick to that. Yeah, it wasn't experimental. And it did work by and large, the show. So can't really argue.
但一个传统的观点是，你不会，我们不会在这个节目中做一次性的实验。你知道，我们讲故事。有一个A、B和C故事，你必须坚持这一点。是的，它不是实验性的。而且它确实在很大程度上奏效了，这个节目。所以真的无法反驳。
But yeah, I'm sort of experimental like you, Rain. I like that kind of thing. I feel like Community did things like that. Yes, every episode. They could get away with that. Really wild one-offs. And I definitely, I'm with you, Rain. I pitched a few times that we would follow characters home.
但是是的，我有点像你，雷恩，喜欢实验。我喜欢那种东西。我觉得《废柴联盟》做过那样的事情。是的，每一集。他们可以逃脱惩罚。非常狂野的一次性节目。我绝对，我和你在一起，雷恩。我推销过几次，我们应该跟着角色回家。
And I was told pretty quickly, but it's the office, it's called the office. We're not going other places. But in this episode, and here's steering us back, we go to Dwight's Beat Farm. So we do go home with a character. And is this, what time is this? Was this the first time, second time we went to Dwight's farm? And was this the first time this was this the first time second time we went to Dwight's farm and was this Gotta be the first time and was it the production of Moe's was this the first time with Moe's? Yeah. Yes
我很快被告知，但这是办公室，它叫办公室。我们不去其他地方。但在这一集中，这里把我们带回来了，我们去了德怀特的甜菜农场。所以我们确实和一个角色回家了。这是，这是什么时间？这是我们第一次，第二次去德怀特的农场吗？这是我们第一次，第二次去德怀特的农场，这是，这一定是第一次，而且是莫斯的制作，这是第一次有莫斯吗？是的。是的
Yes, this episode was history then Yes, so well, let's see Well, let me just say as a writer who obsessed about things like this that the audience didn't give a shit about at the end of the day, which was how would the documentarians be or not be allowed to follow certain things? You know, we would always say you'd never see Jim and Pam's bedroom because they would never invite the cameras there. Are you crazy?
是的，这一集当时就是历史了。是的，那么，好吧，让我们看看。好吧，让我作为一个对这些观众最终根本不在乎的事情感到痴迷的编剧说，那就是纪录片制作者会被允许或不被允许跟随某些事情吗？你知道，我们总是说你永远不会看到吉姆和帕姆的卧室，因为他们永远不会邀请摄像机去那里。你疯了吗？
Whereas Dwight's Beat Farm, the camera crew would be very interested. It's very relevant to this new employee Ryan's journey at Dunder Mifflin. It's very relevant to this major personality at Dunder Mifflin, Dwight. It's fundamental to his nature. We've heard about it a lot. He would be extremely eager to show his Beat Farm, especially as part of a work related milestone for someone in his mind. So it makes total sense. We go to the beat farm. This we spent forever talking about what would it wouldn't happen and what camera angles would and wouldn't be possible. And I don't think the audience cared at all. I did my research and I spent 21 minutes and 40 seconds watching the episode last night.
而德怀特的甜菜农场，摄像组会非常感兴趣。这与这个新员工瑞安在邓德·米夫林的旅程非常相关。这与邓德·米夫林这个主要人物德怀特非常相关。这是他本性的基础。我们听过很多关于它的事。他会非常渴望展示他的甜菜农场，特别是在他看来，作为某人工作相关里程碑的一部分。所以这完全说得通。我们去了甜菜农场。我们花了很长时间讨论什么会发生，什么不会发生，以及什么摄像机角度是可能的，什么是不可能的。而且我不认为观众根本在乎。我做了研究，我昨晚花了21分钟40秒看这一集。
So in preparation for this podcast and it was just a joy to watch. But as I watched that, I was like, oh, this is Pam's episode. It's called the initiation. And yes, the flashy part is, you know, Dwight in the barn and the car and Ryan and the eggs and whatnot. the flashy part is, you k barn and the car and Ryan
所以为了准备这个播客，看这一集真是一种享受。但当我看到那个时，我想，哦，这是帕姆的一集。它叫《引导》。是的，闪亮的部分是，你知道，德怀特在谷仓里，在车里，瑞安和鸡蛋等等。闪亮的部分是，你谷仓和车里，瑞安
whatnot. But but really i of this episode is Pam, y by jam to spy on Michael with Pam and Jim at the e the longest scene. I mean, it must have been a five page scene and had so much heart in it and subtlety. And that's, so I'd love to hear the Pam perspective on this episode.
等等。但但真的这一集是帕姆，由吉姆监视迈克尔，帕姆和吉姆在最后，最长的场景。我的意思是，它一定是一个五页的场景，里面有很多心意和微妙之处。而且那是，所以我很想听听这一集帕姆的视角。
I had forgotten about that scene when I rewatched this episode. I forgot that happened at the end. I did too. I held my breath and I was on the edge of my seat. And I was like, what is happening? Don't get off the phone. Stay on the phone. Say feelings. Say you miss him.
当我重看这一集时，我忘记了那个场景。我忘记了最后发生了什么。我也忘了。我屏住呼吸，坐在座位边缘。我当时想，发生了什么？别挂电话。留在电话上。说出感受。说你想他。
You know, I'm just remembering. It's so funny, Rainn, we were talking about the experimental episode because that card was on the board for a long time, Jim and Pam's phone call. And it was gonna take the whole episode. I fought so hard. I wanted it to be, cause it just happens at the end for a long time, right?
你知道，我只是在回忆。太有趣了，雷恩，我们正在谈论实验性剧集，因为那张卡片在板上放了很长时间，吉姆和帕姆的电话。它会占用整集。我奋斗了很久。我希望它是，因为它只是在最后发生了一段时间，对吧？
The way we shot it. I wanted it to, you keep coming back to it and it's still going and it goes the whole episode. They're on the phone the shot it. I wanted it to keep coming back to it and it's still going. And it goes the whole episode. They're on the phone the whole episode. In the DVD commentary, BJ, you mentioned that in your mind this conversation went on for like three hours. Yeah, that sounds right.
我们拍摄它的方式。我希望它，你不断回到它，它还在继续，它持续了整集。他们在电话里拍摄它。我希望它不断回到它，它还在继续。它持续了整集。他们在电话里整集。在DVD评论中，BJ，你提到在你心中这段对话持续了大约三个小时。是的，听起来是对的。
I wanted it to be threaded through the episode. And then I even wonder if I wanted it to be a whole episode at one point, their phone call, which is again in line with me and Rain's sort of experimental one off outlier episode love. But yeah, I remember that phone call. And I remember writing the line, the one line I remember that I'm proud of is what time zone are you in? Same time zone. Oh, it felt far. I was like, yes, of course. Oh, beautiful felt far. I was like, yes, of course. Beautiful line. That got me in watching this episode. I was like, Oh, this is why this show has stood the test
我希望它贯穿整集。然后我甚至怀疑我是否希望它在某个时候成为整集，他们的电话，这再次符合我和雷恩那种实验性、一次性、离群剧集的爱好。但是的，我记得那个电话。我记得写那句台词，我记得我引以为豪的一句台词是你在哪个时区？同一个时区。哦，感觉很远。我当时想，是的，当然。哦，美丽的台词。这让我看这一集时，我想，哦，这就是为什么这个节目经受住了
of time. Because you have scenes that are outrageously over the top. And then all of a sudden, it's two people in love that hardly know they're in love love having, you know, an almost unedited five minute conversation that it's almost like it's in real time. And you have so this moment of like real heart underneath it that grounds that whole experience. And I always love that Greg talked about having that, you know, a show can't support more than like 10 or 15% hearts. It's got to have 80, 85% comedy in it to work, but you can't leave out that 10, 15% of reality,
时间的考验。因为你有极其夸张的场景。然后突然之间，这是两个相爱的人，几乎不知道他们相爱，进行着，你知道，几乎未经剪辑的五分钟对话，几乎就像是实时的。而且你有这种真实心意的时刻在下面，这让整个体验变得扎实。我一直很喜欢格雷格谈论拥有那个，你知道，一个节目不能支持超过10%或15%的心意。它必须有80%、85%的喜剧才能奏效，但你不能漏掉那10%、15%的现实，
or else you'll have lost the audience. Greg was good with percentages. He also had the 5% rule, which was that every character you should try to move them forward 5%, surprise them 5%. If a character is always exactly what you expect, it gets boring and you fall into cliched ideas of what Angela would do or whatever. cliched ideas of what Angela would do or whatever. But and if you change it by 50 percent or 100 percent, if all of a sudden Michael has read the complete Shakespeare, it's funny, but you killed the character.
否则你就会失去观众。格雷格对百分比很在行。他还有5%规则，那就是每个角色你都应该尝试让他们前进5%，给他们5%的惊喜。如果一个角色总是完全如你所料，它就会变得无聊，你会陷入关于安吉拉会做什么之类的陈词滥调的想法。关于安吉拉会做什么之类的陈词滥调的想法。但是，如果你改变它50%或100%，如果迈克尔突然读完了莎士比亚全集，这很有趣，但你杀死了这个角色。
So you always want to be like, all right, I kind of see that. So yeah, that's just Greg with, if he, I didn't never heard him give that percentage, but that sounds like Greg and sounds right. I just have a question, Rain. When Ryan comes up to to the barn you do the salute and people online think it's like you sort of like Sort of imitating the salute from a BBC show called. Uh, it's called red dwarf
所以你总是想，好吧，我有点明白了。所以是的，那只是格雷格，如果他，我从未听过他给出那个百分比，但这听起来很像格雷格，听起来是对的。我只是有一个问题，雷恩。当瑞安来到谷仓时，你做了那个敬礼，网上的人认为这就像你有点像在模仿BBC节目《红矮星号》中的敬礼。呃，它叫《红矮星号》
Is that is that from red dwarf the BBC show from the 80s I don't remember how that came out, but I, my hunch is that in the script, and you can tell me Dwight does a strange salute or something like that. So I had to kind of come up with what that was. Maybe that's not in the script. I don't know, you can research that. But I don't know what that was. But I like that it's kind of like World War One, Germany, kind of like the Kaiser, like that's how you would salute the Kaiser. Can I point out, I'm realizing this is not our first writer actor collaboration, where
那是来自80年代的BBC节目《红矮星号》吗？我不记得那是怎么出来的，但我的直觉是，在剧本里，你可以告诉我，德怀特做了一个奇怪的敬礼之类的。所以我不得不自己想出那是什么。也许那不在剧本里。我不知道，你可以研究一下。但我不知道那是什么。但我喜欢它有点像第一次世界大战，德国，有点像凯撒，就像那是你向凯撒敬礼的方式。我可以指出，我意识到这不是我们第一次编剧演员合作，
I write a stage direction for Dwight that he makes iconic, which is I can tell you, I know what it is. I remember in the fire. Yes, I do. Iconic, which is I can fire. Yeah, yeah, yeah. In the fire, I wrote The Fire Truck Arrives and Dwight pumps his fist. And I think Greg was like, huh? And I was like, no, he's like a little boy. He just sees a fire truck and he's like, yeah.
我为德怀特写了一个舞台指示，他把它变成了标志性的，也就是我可以告诉你，我知道那是什么。我记得在《火灾》里。是的，我记得。标志性的，也就是我可以火灾。是的，是的，是的。在《火灾》里，我写了消防车到达，德怀特挥舞拳头。我想格雷格当时想，哈？我说，不，他就像个小男孩。他只是看到一辆消防车，他就想，耶。
And you did it. It's great. Now it's like a gif or something. It's like a meme. It's just it's exactly what I dreamed of. And I think. I'm not, you know, we had like gif or something. It's like a meme. It's just, it's exactly what I dreamed of. And I think on that, you know, we had like eight takes or something. So at first it was like standard fist pump and then it got bigger and bigger until finally at the end it's like, yeah. Oh my God. DJ is so tickled. I'm just laughing at how much Dwight loved. It's a toaster oven with a little bit of smoke and he sees a fire
你做到了。太棒了。现在它就像一个GIF之类的。它就像一个模因。这正是我梦想的。而且我认为。我不是，你知道，我们有像GIF之类的。它就像一个模因。这正是我梦想的。而且我认为在那上，你知道，我们拍了八次左右。所以起初它就像标准的挥拳，然后它变得越来越大，直到最后它就像，耶。哦，天哪。BJ太高兴了。我只是在笑德怀特有多喜欢。那是一个带有一点烟的烤面包机，他看到一辆消防
truck and he's like, yes. This is such an excessive solution. Although I suppose that's what happens when the alarm goes off. They just come but it's just like, he would think this is appropriate as opposed to annoying. All right, all right. It would perjury that ranks in like his top 10 best days ever. Like if he was making a journal like Dear Diary,
车，他就想，耶。这是一个如此过度的解决方案。虽然我想当警报响起时就是这样。他们只是来了，但这就像，他会认为这是合适的，而不是烦人的。好吧，好吧。那会是伪证，在他有史以来前10名最好的日子里排名。就像如果他在写日记，亲爱的日记，
best days ever, number four, firetruck showed up to Dunder Mifflin. Another thing I improvised in this episode was in the barn, going back to the barn now, the thing of like, Mo's, where are all the animals? Yes, I was gonna ask you that, Ray. Yeah. I love that line so much.
有史以来最好的日子，第四名，消防车出现在邓德·米夫林。我在这一集中即兴创作的另一件事是在谷仓里，现在回到谷仓，关于莫斯，所有的动物都在哪里？是的，我正要问你那个，雷恩。是的，我非常喜欢那句台词。
But we were laughing, BJ and I, about it on the set and just kind of like, we didn't quite know how to I don't know that it ultimately landed as a joke. But the idea that there should have been it should have been filled with animals. But now it was empty of animals. So what did most do with all the animals? Where did he put them? He probably brought them and put them in the house. And that is that might have been a nice cutaways at most where's all the animals? And then just cut away to Dwight's actual house filled with cows and sheep and pigs
但我们当时在笑，BJ和我，在片场，只是有点像，我们不太知道如何，我不知道它最终是否作为一个笑话落地。但想法是它应该有，它应该装满动物。但现在它没有动物了。所以莫斯用所有动物做了什么？他把它们放在哪里了？他可能把它们带走并放在房子里了。那可能是一个很好的切入镜头，莫斯，所有的动物都在哪里？然后直接切到德怀特真正的房子，里面装满了牛、羊、猪
and chickens and whatnot. Speaking of this scene, can I play an audio clip from this scene? I asked Sam to pull this audio clip from when Dwight is rapid fire questioning Ryan. Can you play that clip, Sam? What is the greatest danger facing Dunder Mifflin? Outsourcing and consolidation of competition. Wrong. Flash floods. What is the true cause of Robert Mifflin's suicide? Depression?
和鸡等等。说到这个场景，我可以播放这个场景的音频片段吗？我让萨姆提取了这个音频片段，当德怀特对瑞安进行快速连珠炮提问时。你能播放那个片段吗，萨姆？邓德·米夫林面临的最大危险是什么？外包和竞争整合。错。山洪暴发。罗伯特·米夫林自杀的真正原因是什么？抑郁症？
Wrong. He hated himself. What is the Dharma Initiative? Final question, young Ryan Howard. What is Michael Scott's greatest fear? Loneliness. Maybe women. Wrong. He's not afraid of anything.
错。他讨厌自己。什么是达摩计划？最后一个问题，年轻的瑞安·霍华德。迈克尔·斯科特最大的恐惧是什么？孤独。也许是女人。错。他不怕任何东西。
Also, I would have accepted snakes. I believe Justin Spitzer wrote that pitch. Justin Spitzer in the writer's room, you send writers off sometimes to just say, all right, you write a bunch of questions, you and you write this scene. I remember Justin coming back with some really good stuff, and I think he wrote Lon loneliness, which I loved.
另外，我会接受蛇。我相信贾斯汀·斯皮策写了那个推销。贾斯汀·斯皮策在编剧室，你有时会把编剧打发走，只是说，好吧，你写一堆问题，你写这个场景。我记得贾斯汀带回了一些非常好的东西，我想他写了孤独，我很喜欢。
But then you said, or maybe fear of women. Yeah, who put maybe women? Loneliness was your first take on Michael's greatest fear. And then you say, or maybe women. And then Dwight is like, false, but I would accept snakes. He's not afraid of anything, but I would have accepted snakes. He's not afraid of anything, but I would have accepted snakes. Right. What a loyalist.
但然后你说，或者也许是害怕女人。是的，谁放了也许是女人？孤独是你对迈克尔最大恐惧的第一个看法。然后你说，或者也许是女人。然后德怀特说，错误，但我会接受蛇。他不怕任何东西，但我会接受蛇。他不怕任何东西，但我会接受蛇。对。多么忠诚。
But guys, this is the scene that introduces Moe's. We were talking about Moe's and Mike Shurer. How did that come about? Everyone wants to know. Mike did an interview where he said that's his real beard and it took him three months to grow. Wait, all of that underneath? Yes, and that is hilarious. That was his hair? Yeah, that's his real hair.
但伙计们，这是介绍莫斯的场景。我们正在谈论莫斯和迈克·舒尔。那是怎么回事？每个人都想知道。迈克做了一个采访，他说那是他真正的胡子，他花了三个月才长出来。等等，下面所有的？是的，这太搞笑了。那是他的头发？是的，那是他真正的头发。
Oh my god. Yes. What an, like, I thought I had it hard having to wear cheesy blonde highlights for six months, but Moe's, Mike had to wear a neck beard. And again, it's only a neck beard. And he's like a classy dude, you know? He's married. He's a TV producer. People know him. He has social engagements.
哦，天哪。是的。多么，就像，我以为我很难，六个月都要戴俗气的金色挑染，但莫斯，迈克不得不戴颈胡。而且再说一次，它只是一个颈胡。而且他是个有品位的家伙，你知道吗？他结婚了。他是一个电视制片人。人们认识他。他有社交活动。
He's walking around with his neck beard, the thick neck beard for months and months and months. And this nothing made Greg Daniels happier or more amused than what Mike had to go through as sort of supervising producer of the office. And yet he also had to wear this neck beard. He never asked to act. And the funniest part of it is that Mike kept asking, don't you think we could just use a fake
他留着颈胡，浓密的颈胡，几个月又几个月。而且这没有什么比迈克作为办公室的监督制片人所经历的一切更让格雷格·丹尼尔斯快乐或感到好笑的了。然而他也必须留这个颈胡。他从未要求表演。最有趣的部分是迈克一直问，你不觉得我们可以只用假
beard? And Greg said, no, absolutely not. People will tell the difference. And then I don't know what the reason was, but maybe it was like, we suddenly came back from, you know, a long hiatus and in a rewrite had to throw Mo's in a scene scene and he didn't have the beard and we just threw a $5 fake beard on it was indistinguishable Totally fine. What now? How did how did they decide Mike sure was going to play his Amish farmer cousin? Yeah, it was I think it was it was 60% confident. It was a room bit.
胡子吗？格雷格说，不，绝对不行。人们会看出区别。然后我不知道原因是什么，但也许就像，我们突然从，你知道，一个漫长的中断中回来，在重写中不得不把莫斯扔进一个场景，他没有胡子，我们只是扔了一个5美元的假胡子，它无法区分，完全没问题。现在什么？他们是怎么决定迈克·舒尔要扮演他的阿米什农民表弟的？是的，我想是，我想是60%的自信。这是一个房间里的笑话。
I think Mike did the voice in sort of a, never thinking it would lead to anything. There's a lot of room bits where you're just joking around for hours, cracking each other up as a way of warming up. And maybe it leads to something, who knows? It's just goofing off. And I think as a room bit, he did that voice and maybe that's what cracked Greg up and made him think.
我想迈克用那种声音，从来没想过它会导致任何事情。有很多房间里的笑话，你只是开玩笑几个小时，互相逗乐，作为热身的一种方式。也许它会导致什么，谁知道呢？这只是在胡闹。我想作为一个房间里的笑话，他用了那个声音，也许这就是让格雷格发笑并让他思考的原因。
So then we took the picture. But I think the idea was always someday we'll see Mo's nudge nudge, but like we didn't even know if we'd be picked up, you know? I do think it was, I do think it was assumed that he would play Mo's if it ever happened. We have a fan question from Quinn Moldenhauer. Finally. Yes. He would like to know.
所以我们就拍了那张照片。但我认为这个想法一直都是总有一天我们会看到莫斯，暗示暗示，但就像我们甚至不知道我们是否会被续订，你知道吗？我确实认为，我确实认为人们假设如果它真的发生了，他会扮演莫斯。我们有一个来自奎因·莫尔登豪尔的粉丝问题。终于。是的。他想知道。
What would have happened if Ryan had actually gotten in the coffin? What were you going to do? Were you going to bury him next to your grandfather? What was going to happen? He was going to put a padlock on the coffin. They were going to wheel it via donkey cart out to the sh
如果瑞安真的进了棺材会发生什么？你们打算做什么？你们打算把他埋在他祖父旁边吗？会发生什么？他打算在棺材上加一把挂锁。他们打算用驴车把它运到
they were going to bury h gonna and he's gonna um m up like a chaplain and do that um Ryan had a taste the sweetness of life and him, Dwight would rescue him and bring the coffin up, throw the dirt off the coffin, undo the padlock, open it up, Ryan would be like, what the fuck Dwight?
他们打算埋他，他会，嗯，像个牧师一样，做那个，嗯，瑞安必须尝尝生活的甜蜜，德怀特会救他，把棺材带上来，把棺材上的土扔掉，解开挂锁，打开它，瑞安会说，该死的德怀特？
And Dwight would be like, I rescued you, Ryan, I rescued you, welcome, you're alive, you made it, you're alive. You're reborn. You're reborn. You're reborn as a Dunder Mifflin employee. And I say to him that this would be a profound experience. That sounds right.
德怀特会说，我救了你，瑞安，我救了你，欢迎，你还活着，你做到了，你还活着。你重生了。你重生为邓德·米夫林的员工。我对他说，这将是一次深刻的经历。听起来是对的。
I like that. Quinn will be very happy to hear. On that note, I'm going to move us along to Axelrod Limited. We find out that they didn't like Ryan. They didn't make the sale. Rain, you have that great line where you're like, I mean, they didn't need to say it to your face. But they didn't like you.
我喜欢那个。奎因听到会很高兴。说到这里，我要带我们进入阿克塞尔罗德有限公司。我们发现他们不喜欢瑞安。他们没有完成销售。雷恩，你有那句很棒的台词，你说，我的意思是，他们不需要当面说。但他们不喜欢你。
That's a really great line. It's really great. But so then you guys end up egging the building. We had a fan question from Chandra who wants to know, did you throw real eggs at the building? Do you guys remember? Yeah, so the Axelrod sign that's hanging up on the side of the building? Do you guys remember? Yeah, so the axle rod sign that's hanging up on the side of the building was a fabrication
那真是一句很棒的台词。真的很棒。但后来你们最终向大楼扔鸡蛋。我们有一个来自钱德拉的粉丝问题，想知道，你们真的向大楼扔鸡蛋了吗？你们记得吗？是的，所以挂在大楼侧面的阿克塞尔罗德标志？你们记得吗？是的，所以挂在大楼侧面的阿克塞尔罗德标志是
from our art department and they hung it up there. And that was our target. And we had worked out with the building itself, like we had a pressure hose right there and they, like as soon as we wrapped, they like took that sign down, pressure washed it cleaned up all the egg everywhere that was kind of part of the contract of the location. Yeah. I remember I can't told me that that building was in the
我们艺术部门制作的，他们把它挂在那里。那是我们的目标。我们和这栋大楼本身商量好了，就像我们那里有一根压力软管，他们，就像我们一结束拍摄，他们就像把那个标志取下来，高压清洗，清理掉到处都是的鸡蛋，这算是地点合同的一部分。是的。我记得我不能告诉我那栋大楼在
parking lot where your trailers were. So when you were shooting in the beat field, this is where they had the craft services. And this is where they had your trailers, and then there was this building. And he said he went in and asked the owner and property manager if they could do this scene. And he was like, no, I just want you to know this includes egging your building.
你们拖车所在的停车场。所以当你们在甜菜田拍摄时，这就是他们提供餐饮服务的地方。这就是他们有你们拖车的地方，然后有这栋大楼。他说他进去问业主和物业经理他们是否可以拍这个场景。他说，不，我只是想让你知道这包括向你的大楼扔鸡蛋。
And he said at this point, the office was so popular that the guy was like, that's fantastic. Yeah, definitely, definitely you can egg my building. Like, he was super on board. It didn't matter. Throw as many eggs at it as you want. Yeah, definitely. Definitely. You can egg my building. Like he was super on board. It didn't matter. Throw as many eggs at it as you want. Ryan and Dwight go on to have drinks at a bar. They do car bombs together.
他说当时办公室太受欢迎了，那个人就觉得，太棒了。没错，绝对可以，你绝对可以往我的大楼上扔鸡蛋。他非常赞同。这根本没关系。想扔多少鸡蛋就扔多少。没错，绝对可以。绝对可以。你可以往我的大楼上扔鸡蛋。他非常赞同。这根本没关系。想扔多少鸡蛋就扔多少。瑞安和德怀特后来去酒吧喝了酒。他们一起喝了爱尔兰炸弹酒。
Dwight calls the temp. You actually call him Ryan. You guys have come together. You've had quite a day. People want to know how many takes did it take for you guys to do all those beers? How many beers did you have? People love asking that question, Jenna. They ask all the time about the cheese puffs,
德怀特给那个临时工打了电话。你其实叫他瑞安。你们两个聚在一起了。你们度过了相当充实的一天。人们想知道你们拍了多少次才拍完那些啤酒镜头？你们喝了多少啤酒？人们很喜欢问这个问题，珍娜。他们总是问关于奶酪泡芙的问题，
how many takes, how many takes of food? It's just a fascinating thing. Yeah, I love it. Behind the scenes for people. I don't remember range, remember? This is an important, I mean, I was watching that scene and I thought how many times did BJ have to chug an entire beer?
拍了多少次，吃了多少次食物？这真是一件令人着迷的事情。是的，我喜欢这样。为观众提供幕后花絮。我不记得范围了，记得吗？这是一个重要的，我是说，我在看那一幕时，我在想BJ得喝多少次整杯啤酒？
A fake beer. Well, it wouldn't have been beer, yeah. It would have been a fake beer. Near beer, but- But it's a lot of liquid. Probably two or three, but I probably got it in the second take, you know, and moved on.
假啤酒。嗯，那不可能是啤酒，是的。那会是假啤酒。无醇啤酒，但是——但这液体量很大。大概两三次吧，但我可能在第二次拍摄时就搞定了，你知道的，然后继续拍下一场。
Yeah, I don't remember. It was one setup, yeah. There you have it, guys. Thank you so much for doing this podcast with us today. It was so wonderful to see you again. This was a lot of fun. Thanks. Thank you.
是的，我不记得了。那是一个场景设置，是的。就是这样，伙计们。非常感谢你们今天和我们一起录制这期播客。再次见到你们真是太好了。这真的很有趣。谢谢。谢谢。
It's so nice to see your faces here on this Zoom. It's delightful. I miss you all. And I had such warm, fuzzy feelings. This was such a pleasure and a joy. I don't buy it. Oh, come on. So cynical.
能在Zoom上看到你们的脸真是太好了。太令人高兴了。我想念你们所有人。我心里感到暖洋洋的。这真是一种快乐和享受。我不信。噢，别这样。太愤世嫉俗了。
Bye. Bye office ladies. All right guys, that was so great. Angela, how much fun was it to see them and hear from them? I mean, I loved hearing BJ's insights into the writer's room. That was, I'm a nerd for that though. I love any writer's room info.
再见。再见，办公室女士们。好了伙计们，这太棒了。安吉拉，见到他们并听到他们的分享有多开心？我是说，我喜欢听BJ对编剧室的见解。那是，虽然我对此是个书呆子。我喜欢任何关于编剧室的信息。
I could have listened to BJ talk for like on and on and on because I thought it was so fascinating just to hear the process. And I think you and I share that. I love hearing the process of it all. So BJ, you have to come back. And Rainn, you were delightful too, Rainn. Yes, that was such a treat to have them both. Well, listen, before we wrap up this episode, I do want to add two more things, Angela.
我可以一直听BJ讲下去，因为我觉得听到这个过程非常迷人。我想你和我都有同感。我喜欢听这一切的过程。所以BJ，你一定要再来。还有雷恩，你也很可爱，雷恩。是的，能同时邀请到他们真是太棒了。好了，听着，在结束这一集之前，我还要补充两件事，安吉拉。
One is from Randall Einhorn. When I was talking to him, he put this thought in my head and I just loved it. He said that for him, the theme of this episode that he really wanted to highlight as a director was this idea of making connections. He said, Ryan and Dwight make a connection. Even after the craziness of the day, they connect and Ryan really learns something. Stanley and Michael make a connection through the pretzels and of course Jim and Pam. He just said that that theme of making connections is an overriding one for him with the office
第一件事来自兰德尔·艾恩霍恩。当我和他交谈时，他给了我一个想法，我非常喜欢。他说对他来说，这一集他作为导演真正想强调的主题是建立联系这个想法。他说，瑞安和德怀特建立了联系。即使在这一天经历了疯狂之后，他们还是建立了联系，瑞安真的学到了一些东西。斯坦利和迈克尔通过椒盐卷饼建立了联系，当然还有吉姆和帕姆。他只是说，建立联系这个主题对他来说是《办公室》中一个压倒性的主题，
and it's something he loves, but he thought it was particularly highlighted in this episode. And I just thought that was a really, a really cool observation. Yeah, I think that's really beautiful. I find that Randall points out these themes to us all the time, whether it's about camera placement
这是他喜欢的东西，但他认为在这一集中得到了特别的强调。我只是觉得这是一个非常非常酷的观察。是的，我觉得这真的很美。我发现兰德尔总是向我们指出这些主题，无论是关于摄像机的位置，
or whether you could see Pam's face after the kiss. Like Randall is really great about hitting these deeper layers of the show and what they're talking about in each episode. And then finally, this was some fan mail that we got from Amanda Bistek. She said, guys, Google Shroot Farms trip advisor. You will not be disappointed. And I did, Angela.
还是你是否能在吻戏后看到帕姆的脸。兰德尔真的很擅长挖掘节目的深层含义以及他们在每一集中讨论的内容。最后，这是我们从阿曼达·比斯特克那里收到的一些粉丝来信。她说，伙计们，谷歌搜索“施鲁特农场猫途鹰”。你们不会失望的。我照做了，安吉拉。
There is a trip advisor page for Shroot Farms. And there are hundreds of comments of people who claim to have stayed there. It's a fake page. But the comments are really amazing if you're an Office fan, because they have all these details as if they had stayed there. Oh my gosh, I wonder if people go on it and think it's an actual thing. I don't know. That is so funny. I love that. I'm gonna and think it's an actual thing. I don't know. That is so funny. I love that.
猫途鹰上确实有一个施鲁特农场的页面。有数百条评论，人们声称曾住在那里。这是一个虚假的页面。但如果你是《办公室》的粉丝，这些评论真的很棒，因为他们有所有这些细节，就好像他们真的住过那里一样。天哪，我不知道人们是否会点进去并认为这是一个真实存在的地方。我不知道。这太搞笑了。我喜欢这个。
I'm gonna have to check that out, Amanda. Thanks for. Yeah, you have to check it out. So guys, there it is. That's initiation. And we will be back next week with Diwali. Diwali. And another special guest.
我得去看看，阿曼达。谢谢你。是的，你一定要去看看。好了伙计们，就是这样。这就是入职仪式。我们下周会回来讨论《排灯节》。排灯节。还有另一位特别嘉宾。
Yes, we have someone really special stopping by next week. You guys are gonna be so excited. I'm so excited. So we'll see you next week. You guys are gonna be so excited. I'm so excited. So we'll see you next week and thanks so much, BJ and Rain. Yeah, guys, if you wanna hear more of Rain's voice, you can listen to him discussing life's big questions on his podcast, Metaphysical Milkshake,
是的，下周有一位非常特别的人会来做客。你们会非常兴奋的。我太兴奋了。所以我们下周见。你们会非常兴奋的。我太兴奋了。所以我们下周见，非常感谢BJ和雷恩。是的，伙计们，如果你想听到更多雷恩的声音，你可以去听他在他的播客《形而上学的奶昔》中讨论人生重大问题，
which can be found on the Luminary app. We love you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins
可以在Luminary应用程序上找到。我们爱你们。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，
and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weis-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴西尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。